all right friends and neighbors you know
what to do if we are live
let us know
we cannot go
live properly until you tell us that
we're live yeah also we know hit that
thumbs up if you like that thumbnail
shouts out to my sister she often helps
us make all the thumbnails thumbnails
i don't know how to do that she spent
like three two to three hours on it
she's amazing megan alba
uh are we live you guys gotta tell us if
we're live
jeffrey timberton jake robles
what have you done chris charlotte
can i say i'm honored that you guys made
me the irishman but also terrified that
you were like send me this photo and i
did and it's way scarier like it's way
more intense than i was prepared for
i was like i told my sister like just
stretch his face out to make it look
more penguin here
did what i could make it bigger all
right guys while we're in the chat i
want to thank koi for being here uh
we're gonna get straight to it a little
bit quicker than usual and uh thank you
for everyone who's here so far uh quick
shout outs to quentin steve kenny
camilla disney fan juice
okay i can't keep up right now that's a
good problem can we do slower mode on
the chat it's been a while since i don't
live in a live stream in a couple of
months yeah yeah i haven't been live in
a while there's a way to there's a way
to slow it down everyone that hates me
on this channel i'm the reason we're
doing this because i'm like we're gonna
be live talk so take your hate
to me
i thought uh i thought this was like a
marvel movie but without the comedy yeah
where's the were the jokes or the jokes
lots of jokes this movie is actually
very funny i i actually the criticism i
usually can like understand it like i
can put myself in someone else's shoes
most of the critique is actually just
dumb like let me use the word dumb don't
be mean no but the dumb the people are
don't be happy you have a critique
you're an idiot but like in this case i
read most the rotten tomatoes rottens
and a lot of them are really like you
didn't smile enough they're like bros
girls
yeah yeah yeah dumb critique i feel like
uh
did you see scott mance's tweet review i
feel like you should just come out and
say it like that what did he say he just
said like i hated this it was
like all dark all dreary no point
nothing fun i hated this
i just went for it and i was just like
you know what fine i first heard you if
you don't like what this is about the
first time we saw the batman uh at the
screening scott mance was there he was
i'm pretty sure he never remembers me no
matter how many times i've been on
camera that's so funny i was like hey
scott it's like
hey
i just saw the idea
like i think i know you
even though we've done some videos
together i uh i just i usually like i
said i can put myself in the position of
even when you know greg who happy
birthday
um hater of eternals greg alba when he
was giving his justified issues with the
film i knew where he was coming from but
a lot of these people like do they know
who batman is
well the thing that i
actually can understand
even though i think even though i'm not
in the camp that goes [ __ ] that uh but
the one criticism that i can kind of get
on board with if i'm being completely
frank and then we'll start getting to
the questions and stuff thank you guys
i'm reading i'm also reading comments
while talking to you guys been a while
we've been live just give us like five
minutes to get really used to this koi
goes live more often
all the time
so
the criticism about like let's talk
about the bruce wayne thing really quick
and then we'll hop into your questions
and such um
with bruce wayne of being a major
recluse and not putting on that alter
ego personality i think the movie
justifies it well first off like i think
the movie handles it very well and then
even alfred at one point says you know
like you have to keep up appearances
he's like i don't wanna and then and
then you know when he's like he doesn't
go out in the day even when he's at the
funeral there's a guy there who's like
[ __ ] billionaires who are you like
like he's not even recognizable anymore
that's how saying a guy that lives in a
cave by a butler is not so socialized
but the reason why i don't one reason
why i can't fault people for thinking
that a we've been conditioned to think
that's how batman operates all the time
that's why the way it is
what's up apparently my mic is low i was
trying not to interrupt you that's fine
so apparently because i think we've been
conditioned to think that that like oh
to always think that's what it's going
to be even batman begins which is an
origin movie he sets out and in batman
year one the comic he comes back to
gotham with the plan to put on the
persona and to be batman like he has
that as a plan so i think because we've
been pre-programmed to go he must do
that is why i think some of us
some people have a hard time getting on
board with it but for the world created
here for the more realistic
interpretation and for what matt reeves
set out to do
it doesn't bother me for this take and
there are versions where he is like that
my greatest like the moment that really
sung for me about that whole thing was
he literally fed him berries like a bat
like when he was like i made you some
fresh berries like he's more bat than
man because yes the classic metaphor is
not metaphor the classic category of the
concept of the batman is the real hymn
and the mask is bruce wayne the mask of
bruce wayne hasn't been developed yet
and the end of the movie this is a
spoiler talk this is the only warning
i'm going to give you is about him
finding a reason to invent that persona
because the town needs hope the city of
gotham doesn't need vengeance since it
needs hope so he goes from i'm vengeance
to i'm batman bruce goes from i am a
human being that doesn't know what i am
to i need to figure out how to represent
something beyond vengeance so i love the
idea of this kurt cobain uh obviously
inspired uh reclusive but to an 11
because homeboy is living in a cave so
uh he's going to maybe even not invent
the bruce wayne person to the level we
are but i would imagine he would in the
next film and i imagine it's going to be
about him trying to rebuild gotham as a
symbol of hope and therefore needing to
be the public persona of bruce wayne as
well as it's robert pattinson the man is
bruce wayne he's a guy that walks around
being handsome and rich that can't
actually interact with society like if
you've seen tennant if you've seen uh
cosmopolis if you've seen
paparazzi video the dude can do this so
i just the idea that he can't play bruce
wayne is short-sighted in the idea that
this bruce wayne would already be at
this point doesn't make any sense and i
know people are like it's year two he
should not do this why he hasn't needed
to he went out for the first time to a
funeral that's not where you playboy it
up i just this critique
i've had i've had a long week of this
ish yeah you engaged with too many
people i did i did
this is the way the most i've ever
engaged the internet this week and i
feel like bruce wayne every tweet i put
out i go no look into the comments right
now and i'm like i will find you
um how is the is the sound okay right
now guys
i want to say it's because we haven't
gone live in a while but i know even
when we were consistently going live we
have
[Laughter]
so but does it sound okay right now i
just want to make sure that everything
someone just donated 500
what like real 500
oh my holy [ __ ] balls 500 mexican
dollars oh mexican dollars i think is
that what mx is oh that's like uh
it's like two dollars
i don't know hey no matter what it is we
appreciate you
we are unworthy
that's your five that's wait look we and
whatever you guys contribute that it
means the world are like seriously these
are hard earned dollars thank you yeah
it's all going to pay back koi you know
that's really fun come in here and i'm
like i have a five grand an hour
retainer like matt murdock
[ __ ] here
god let's get some super chats jesus
christ that's right batman never leave
things like coy's on the show
i'm sorry
please don't hurt me
i'm just [ __ ] like adam sandler not
coach
i don't know what's happening
like
how do we like that let's do it or
sandler you put out a pole let's root
with that pull all righty
how did you feel about the batman 12
percent of you liked it
54 of you loved it
and uh three percent of you gotta have
it no three percent of you weren't about
it and uh for 31 you think it's the best
live-action batman movie thus far that's
great to hear good turnout i'm not gonna
lie about it you know i'm always a
little bit nervous before going live uh
i even told you that i was yesterday i
meant you to come like a little nervous
about doing a live stream and then
whenever we come back i go it's the best
you know these are sometimes more fun
than shooting like the other videos
there's there's a connection yeah
they're just spontaneous you don't have
to worry about editing or like keeping
everything super efficient chaos i just
do weekly lives but then youtube's like
we don't like those so it kept drowning
my channel john campio yeah the boss the
sound is clean everything's
characterized thanks for the comments
guys all right yeah let's read some uh
some some some stuff that came in thank
you guys for your support also i'm gonna
throw this out periodically if you have
a tick tock
follow coindro he's constantly posting
videos he talks theories easter eggs
breakdowns of things trying to be
relevant to that
toy knowledge
you know go to tick tock tick tock coin
was that your ticket yeah i don't use
tickets i like your website.com
number 52
all right we'll be up here with the
super chats in a hot second in the
meantime you know what let me pull up
the live on my phone so that way it's
easier oh i like to read smarter
yeah i see some super chat action don't
worry don't worry koi i'm just trying to
get you you'll get what you want
to take
over get to the bat we'll get to the
joker one in a second uh we will get to
the joker appreciate the question
barry cogan that [ __ ] leaked early as
[ __ ] yeah they really did months ago
yeah that has like so many confirmations
we're is like apparently his like little
brother was like yeah her brother was
like got out now and then he tried to
lean i'm like dude dude it's too late
yeah you're too late everyone everybody
knows i can't undo a tweet like that's
not where things go i can't edit it oh
barry cogan
uh yeah let's break this down guys this
is a thick ass movie we've seen it three
times each yep
nine hours this week robert pattinson
was at our imax screening and this guy
mr schmooze over here so i was like i
was i was with your guest and they were
sitting next to me
and i was like this is so annoying you
know you buy people tickets and they're
all just [ __ ] outside while we're uh
they're all gonna show up right when
this movie starts they're probably gonna
be a little late they're gonna be those
annoying ass people and then robert
bennett showed up
and i was like that's how you get your
[ __ ] i was meeting people i was
having a good time i was drinking a
drink called the bat outside and then i
went to pee because i know there's no
moment in this three hour movie to go
pee so out of respect for the movie i
missed robert pattinson he'd understand
man if anyone's gonna get it it's our
pets sure sure all right let's get to it
all right alif bae
bae roslyn you see that john yes i can
love the movie i'm seeing it again
tonight i was wondering where you see
the next two films going which villains
aside from the joker do you think they
should focus on you know i didn't
actually think about this villain ever
even after watching the movie i kind of
have a bit of a hard time imagining it
but i know koi is a big champion i
imagine john would really love this
i i personally would want a scarecrow to
be redone
three movies with scarecrow
kind of he was never like the threat or
the real like yes
and
you're right you're right
when batman finds out who he is he
immediately like finds him beats and
uses his own toxin
and he's always a [ __ ] in the other one
but i love him but he's not really a
[ __ ] and dark knight rises yeah he's
running the kangaroo
but anyway i want a proper scarecrow
redone but matt reeves uh touched on mr
freeze out of anyone three mr freeze
with matt reeves
please
uh i am going to go against the grain
and say i don't think they should do the
joker next uh and i know that is no one
i don't really i'm going to interrupt
you for one sec i already didn't dribble
i just don't know anyone who
we've been to three screenings and now
i've never seen anyone in the audience
get excited when that joker shows up it
should have been a post-credits scene
yeah and it also like i don't know that
joker we i have had a movie where the
first film teases the joker and then
he's in the second movie we've already
had that trilogy i also think that we've
had joaquin's joker we've had little
joker we've had heath's joker which is
formative but i personally want to see
some more detective-esque villains so
like if they do the joker they've kind
of set up war of jokes and riddles which
i would enjoy because that's a different
take on the joker because in war of
jokes and riddles the joker doesn't want
to laugh like he's lost his sense of
humor so the riddler is trying to make
the joker laugh that's a fun different
take and that's a way more mafia take on
the joker which i could see this barry
kogan take doing because apparently it's
uh he's got like a birth defect that
makes him smile all the time and he's
like this mafia type dude we've already
met him in this universe in the two
years we've met the joker as a not fully
formed joker that's the rumor that being
said i wouldn't mind if we keep the
joker in arkham tucked away and he's got
this foreboding behind the scenes like
one day he's coming and you do villains
we haven't seen before or we've only
seen as arnold schwarzenegger like we do
villains that we've seen in the in the
big sense and what i the reason i'm
bringing scarecrow as a negative is
we've had three scarecrow movies two
various levels of happiness i think
killian murphy plays a great scarecrow
in the nolan take on it but you could do
a mad hatter and do a lot of the things
you do with scarecrow with a new villain
and i'd go like a ben foster mad hatter
like a very intense manic mad hatter and
then you can get a lot of your scarecrow
elements but with a new take do you
think they should redo harvey dent
properly i think that the i think the
next movie should be
dent was bad i mean it's perfect aaron
redempton is like damn near perfect it's
great but i like the fact that they
killed him off and he doesn't rise to
like crying lord i would introduce
harvey in the next film as the new da
because they need one um and i would
introduce uh the idea of the court of
owls looming like i would plant some
seeds and then i would do a hush court
of owl's third film and i would do a mr
freeze uh
i would actually do like kind of a
romance story because you'd need um mr
freeze and nora freeze i would have them
as scientists in love and he wouldn't be
mr freeze until like late second act and
that way you've got a reason for bruce
wayne to exist maybe bruce wayne's
invested in frieza's technology and that
way you care about mr freeze and you
care about bruce wayne more you can do
the playboy stuff and then every time
bruce wayne and mr freeze fight you care
for both of them so every punch lands
twice so i would do like i'd honestly do
a nicholas sparks mr freeze movie
separate and then put it in batman and
i'd have like [ __ ] ryan gosling i'd
have a handsome mr freeze someone you
invest in someone you care about the
relationship of and then you do that
movie to uh build to the third with
quarterbacks
i'm sold koi nicholas sparks is mr
freeze how long each question is gonna
take this is gonna be a six hour live
stream i just want my solomon grundy
movie please
that would be perfect they could do so
much spooky in this i know and he would
be like how great would that like find a
way to bring it down to earth and then
have him be this strange
presence in the sewers and whatnot plus
that character has a lot of like fight
for the morality of like are you gonna
be a tool for organized crime or are you
going to actually
not do that and maybe be some kind of
anti hero like i don't know if you could
base a whole movie around him but i've
been dying to see a live action opening
fight and like have you know the moments
that like you know you love i love when
comic movies are like this is how far
things have come this is how much better
he is at this have that be the the you
know precedent i wanted andy circus to
be clay-faced before they announced he
was alfred i thought it'd be fun to have
indy circus doing a hundred different
voices i'm gonna stop talking
first question also shout out
[Laughter]
within an hour from now when people are
like hey have you gone into my question
yet and then everyone's saying that
quick shouts out to joseph prashasga in
the chat uh did anyone else think it was
too faced yes at the end i i when i
first saw his actual face i was like
they doing a weird take on harvey here
i think it's greg capullo's two face
where he staples the face onto his face
i think he's actually scarred and bring
it yeah i
my favorite part of the new movies
coming out is watching your live stream
afterwards always something to look
forward to thank you guys for everything
thank you brandon that's very sweet of
you thank you brandon really appreciate
it why weren't you here for our
uncharted livestream yeah why weren't
you here first
any of you here oh dude our entire
livestream
we invited you to be on it
took off million views uncharted bigger
than the boxes
live stream so many questions
came right tom holland was here we got
the sequel green live yes i'm proud of
you
mark wahlberg's mustache was here but
not mark wahlberg it was uh it was not a
success that live stream laura croft's
two guns showed up wearing mark
wahlberg's mustache the puppet actually
there was a guy in the live stream
anthony who pitched uh mr freeze in an
ice truck and kind of like richard
kochlinski the iceman which i think is
actually
a really neat take i like that lab
michael shannon mister oh yes yeah all
right yeah the pipette thanks the
pipette saw this movie in imix and got
food poisoning from the popcorn i don't
know it's possible we're worth it
[Laughter]
my ear mine is a there's a one of koi's
drinks is blocking off your
thing so i thought it's worthless
worthless
worth nothing if i can't keep my corn
down yeah man uh what theater did you go
to because
every time i go to amc their popcorn
gets me sick every single time no [ __ ]
you still keep doing it i just don't you
just said it like you were in a computer
position
man they're like you know you get a
medium it's a free large upgrade oh [ __ ]
yeah i'll get largely
large instead of getting mediums i can
get large sizes i have endured so many
looks going to the movie theaters when
i'm like i i just don't need the extra i
don't need a bucket of a drink and like
you know a barrel of popcorn i'm sorry
i'll just pay a little more for less
food
beautiful ending batman leading the
citizens of gotham out of the darkness
with a torch in hand i got emotional
every i got emotional watching at lol
every time we have seen this i have shed
tears during that moment
in particular when i when we did our
non-spoiler talk right out of the
theater when i was saying like i'm not
sure if i'm emotionally as emotionally
invested in this as i like to be
and then i said like oh [ __ ] i'm crying
um when i was talking about that in the
review it was that moment
where i was and it's like it's not just
like a good isolated scene that only
works if i'm actually invested right and
because of the fact that when he like
jumps down there and does that
he's uh i love the i think what a lot of
people don't point out is also the
mirror
there's a cat who's meowing and he's not
in pain you guys can't hear him he just
wants to attach it to it's just freaking
much do you hear that that is literally
caterpillar
stop live streaming play with me
um it's when at the very beginning of
the movie uh when he beats up those uh
guys on halloween there's the dude who
he saves who's like don't hurt me please
he's terrified of him the dude he saved
is terrified of him and it's it's a
mirrored shot where like batman's
looking down at him
consumed by water and then at the end of
the movie batman's looking down at
people consumed by water as the first
time i hope don't hurt me it's yeah now
it's saved me yeah and and it's a good
mirroring and that person on the
stretcher i i love that moment too
because it's that like i i don't want to
leave your presence i feel safe you're
the one that's helped please
let me know it's okay to go with these
people like uh yes and to be honest
that's a beautiful
this is going to be true sorry in
advance that's a beautiful this is
batman as opposed to some of the other
batman's people are enjoying in pop
culture like this batman very much makes
a point of not using guns and very much
makes a point of not killing you can be
left on the freeway i mean sometimes you
gotta kill the freeway
but like there there is a there's a
merit to pointing out very clearly he
doesn't use guns he doesn't kill and
he's a force of hope because if he just
stays a force of fear the whole point of
the movie is he's not just vengeance and
i really love that they're they're
making that the first movie like this
isn't the batman that kills and i really
like that it's the batman who laughs
not yet i think they only call him i
think chris stuckman pointed this out um
that they only call him batman i think
twice in this movie he says it once
maybe the end of the batman and then um
they're saying
yeah the writer says a lot but he he's
mostly vengeance yeah mr vengeance yeah
mr vengeance here
there's so many great little nuances
poven meyer thank you pope meyer i
honestly thought the riddler was gonna
end up being tommy elliot aka hush who
wants revenge as falcone uh killed
edward elliott for thomas huane
well i think in order because i need to
remember the comic properly
wait is it actually riddler who's doing
it or did they [ __ ] or is it the
animated
yeah the animated movie is the one that
[ __ ] up yeah yeah and the comic goes
mislead then the animator was like [ __ ]
it we'll do the misleading yes yes yeah
yeah so i think in order for the mislead
to work you know you need to establish
who the riddler is first yeah because if
this is batman's first time meeting
brothers it doesn't work that's the
point of misleading yes guys actually
i don't feel hoodwinked at all
so um but i think hush is coming no i
mean like the producer did an interview
on the red carpet with brandon davis and
he was saying like yeah they were going
through like every comic and he just
like matt reeves just [ __ ] consumed
every comic so there's a lot that you
could already see on display here
there's a lot of com see i thought this
was mainly gonna be like film influence
movie which it is but it was also so
comic book like there's so many comments
long halloween year one batman ego year
zero especially surprisingly at the end
like there's a lot of like very iconic
frames in this yeah man they even
brought the carmine falcon um that's one
of the long halloweens long halloween
tim sale yeah
uh with the
with the catwoman being and the year one
the diner straight from year one like
they literally grabbed a frame from year
one and then put the riddler in it which
and it also mirrors that famous art
piece which is cool because the comic
mirrored the art piece first and then he
was able to frame it like the art piece
and the comic and a lot of people were
like oh it's that famous piece of art
but it's also the comic which is dope
you know mel gibson would be a great
solomon grundy my k let's move on here
this is a public service announcement
sold if you love the batman and want to
see more catwoman there's a great direct
video animated film called catwoman
hunted available to buy and or rent a
cat woman i want to see more catwoman i
do want to see more cats the first thing
i said walking out was that i wanted
more zombie crowds you know what i'm
loving about when i go online
a lot of women i'm not saying all women
yes all women i have okay yes and all
ladies are saying this you have a
universal hive
out of context and delete everything but
this oh no like so many women i
encounter are like man that catwoman
batman [ __ ] is so hot oh it is
but as as a guy living today i'm like is
this gonna be perceived as creepy but
then all the women i'm talking to are
like damn it's so hot
oh my god okay we're [ __ ] loud damn
hands not cancer dude i was so i was in
man
he like grabs her at the beginning when
the cops coming in he's just like he has
big ass arms wrapped around no of course
that moment yeah i'm like uh how's this
gonna be okay but he's doing it to
protect her so it's hot and it's [ __ ]
hot
also like we need to have like more of
the bdsm community represented in comic
book movies like we have a little taste
of pegging and deadpool but there's a
lot more out there guys there's some
diversity a lot of sexual awakenings all
these down on you
i've got the mask for it it's not
allowed guys no no maybe it is now oh i
think they had enough kickback we might
see a little cat linger
i would love some wokeness people can
get on board yeah so kyle's heroes
i love their women they do kyle arcing
in the chat wants to see a deacon
blackfire story uh come to the big
screen
thank you i thought that was good i just
thought that was an interesting deep cut
anyway righteous rob what would you say
is different about the batman about this
batman
uh i mean most things so much for
starters to bruce wayne i think like the
riddler especially i think what's so
unique about this one is exactly it's
because matt reeves didn't want to i got
this guys i just gotta hit darkness
there we go and stop recording get a
little bit of buttons on screen for a
tiny bit it'll go away um
so instead of watching john frantically
let's have one more second
like a gazillion things that's right
the modesty bar at the bottom of the
screen presents you from seeing oh yeah
let's give
[Music]
um so yeah i mean i think that what
makes this one especially unique is the
fact of how many
the way how like comics can often borrow
from film genre and then then it becomes
kind of a cyclical nature with this
movie i think is what's so neat about it
because it's everything matt reeves said
it was gonna be and you rarely get that
i remember like alex kurtzman who's the
guy who did uh the mummy movie was alex
kurtzman yes yeah alex kirsten when
doing the mummy was like yeah you know i
started we were going back to like the
traditional universal monsters and
really wanted to capture that spirit and
you hear that [ __ ] all the time and you
watch that movie you're like that dude's
a [ __ ] lost it did not work out for
him it's not just an action movie like
it's really the horror tradition i'm
like no and then like you know freaking
even even nolan talking about tennis
like yeah it's kind of like a bond movie
i'm like not really man but then
then here like this is so much more matt
reeves said it was going to be it is
film and comic just combined and because
it takes its time you can really feel
all the influences i'm going to make a
big statement that i think people are
going to see is hyperbole i think this
is the movie as much as logan was that's
going to save the medium i don't
consider it a genre anymore the medium
of comic book film because this was a
film and like logan walked so this could
run like this is a
this is the strength of this is this is
not for everyone the strength of this
movie is that the average
zealot
might not like it and that is the
bravery of wb and dc for being like hey
we're gonna make something that's not
for everyone every single comic book
movie is made for everyone this wasn't
like the point of making comic book
movies is to have a giant box office so
you can make other movies that can kind
of keep your entire studio moving and
grooving this was the opposite they were
like we're gonna make an art house film
that's gonna be three hours largely
silent [ __ ] and score long holding
shots that's not a comic book movie so i
love that this means we get an entirely
new trajectory so what's different about
this is the fact that they trusted their
filmmaker to make a piece of art instead
of something that's going to appeal to
everybody what they made was a graphic
novel movie yeah that's what i would put
it one more or something oh it's just so
no john please no it's something with
just as many uh cinema references to
pick out and someone is just as many
references to classic films as it has
references to comic books when you were
so greg saw it before me and i predicted
way more than because because of my
comic knowledge then i was so afraid i'd
figured out the movie so i was texting
greg like oh no i think i put together
too much and greg because he's a good
friend very much was like maybe like you
did he actually neutraled him but what's
funny is i struggle with 70 cinema like
i struggle with that kind of pace and
and it's so fun though
so that's that's not generally for me
but it's so that was a really great text
from gregory's like i'm never going to
like it bro i i downplayed it for
many people like not for you guys so
when i decided to review but in person
where people want to get into a
conversation you could ask anyone i
talked to i downplayed it it's in my top
five superhero movies and i thank you
for downloading it because if you'd said
it was gonna be my top five yeah yeah
cause i i what i really wanted to prep
people for is that it's it's not a
it's not the fast pacing it doesn't
exactly capture what the
it's it's more deliberate than what the
trailers represent it's more akin to the
first trailer but the trailers still
have you feeling like this is going to
be like a pulse-pounding exciting film
when i'm really like no that's more of
like a mood uncomfortable
piece observant colder and then then it
gets like oh i have it has a heart
there's one like five million worked for
where i think it's like the trailers are
great whereas like uh where i think
where logan you know has more of a heart
throughout and uh because you didn't
feel like i had a heart on top
uh i felt like you have to i think on a
second viewing i found the heart earlier
on
yeah because i feel like it's really
cold for a long time until like the end
when i'm like oh [ __ ] no it does happen
it had to be cold to get warm yeah and
i'm not a very i'm not i it's weird is i
really like their performances isolated
and i like them working together but i
never really felt
like that uh strong connection to their
to the romantic chemistry of batman and
catwoman interesting did you feel the
chemistry between gordon and batman that
[ __ ] every time every time every time
that might be a question i jumped ahead
yeah oliver heimlin or hamlin uh what up
guys big fan we're a big fan of you
hello what'd you do uh i loved the
arkham scene between batman and riddler
uh paul dano killings
oh
this is
not how i was supposed to go
i
i have loved him increasingly each time
though uh paul dano dano apparently is
the pronunciation as per every late
night talk show i've watched him on uh
killed it and made me want more
masculist riddler what were your
standout scenes
uh i'll tell you my chunks i imagine
there'll be more specific questions here
later other than the big heroic moment
at the end
uh there's a chunk of the film that
every time i watch it i'm like like we
did a video now longer that was called
the perfect sequence from spider-man
something like that and there's like a
solid 20 minutes of the film and i think
that one at the funeral scene
ending on
when alfred's build when when uh bruce
thinks alfred's been killed
that whole chunk right there 20 minutes
of pure cinema it's a little bit longer
than 20 minutes uh it felt great it's
probably like 40 minutes really maybe
it's the funeral scene every scene in
this movie is like 20 minutes long so
it's like the funeral scene and then
it's him in the police station then it's
him on the bat wing and it's when he
flies out then it then they find the
penguin and they go on the dr and then
they go on the car chase and they
interrogate penguin yeah and they find
the
the
what is the deal called the
the our deal the renewal deal renewal
deal with thomas wayne and then he's
driving and i love that shot too when
batman is like trying to get to alfred
and then when he yells they don't have
they don't hear him yell yeah
yeah and then then he's and i love the
way they played with time there
christopher nolan you know what you're
playing
so but yeah i love the way they played
with that time did you get the good time
i caught the good times easter eggs i
did not catch it but i saw it
yeah yeah i saw it i thought it was the
time and i just didn't yeah yeah i was
thinking about it
just like this
maybe that's what a chain i don't know
and then everybody's like easter egg and
i was like oh i didn't overthink it well
and then hearing that that was the movie
that made matt reeves really want him
that was like ah
after that movie everyone wanted robert
for me it was the rover man rover sold
me on on our pets the rover watson it's
okay buddy quick cruise of the chat
folks want to see poison ivy i see a
ventriloquist killer croc deacon
blackfire bane people want mr freeze or
court of owls in here a lot of mr
freezing cordovals mad hatter some hush
hells yeah guys thank you for chiming in
just trying to pay some love to the main
chat as well uh reynaldo torres torres
can't believe i'm saying this but in
some way i loved this more than no way
home the batman made me feel like a kid
in the theater watching a comic come to
life the whole theater was an awe 10 out
of 10. i'm glad you had such a wonderful
experience you know what i noticed on
imax viewing every time i ever go to the
theaters
someone whips out their phone no someone
not a single and i had the perfect seat
i managed to snag the perfect dead
center seat that is the top row at
universal ima that's what you want when
you're going to that theater
so i get access to everything
i've seen it three times so sometimes
there's like look around it's gonna see
what the audience is reacting like and i
couldn't and but the audience is so
quiet and still and
not one person whipped out their phone
not once someone had their phone out at
one of my screenings in the first like
five minutes and i was so angry and they
were they were like right here and they
literally had their phone out and they
were reading something and typing they
were a two phone [ __ ] and i literally
all i had to say was oi and like
everyone in the theater [ __ ] turned
on with yeah it was this really
beautiful like we're all [ __ ] here
bro and i've never seen a universal like
we will fight you yeah and it was
similar in the opposite way where it was
like we're all here for the right reason
because i would say no way home is like
when i want to be happy like if i need
pure joy i watch no way home because it
is
just goodness it's nostalgia it's
actually yeah but like if i want to
[ __ ] vibe i'ma watch the batman now
like when this is on hbo i'm actually
april 19th i'm gonna [ __ ] vibe all
the time living in gotham because this
is my favorite like movie
atmospherically
this and dune are the most i've ever
been like yo i'm gonna live in this
space and that is saying something for a
comic book movie and i think well the
thing is i think it rises above like
good for a comic book movie is that a
pun you know what i mean because uh did
the dark knight rise for you
yeah give me like 20 more minutes i'll
be all goofy again okay
so
but yeah at the uh
but yeah i think in the for no caffeine
today guys apologies so the um what were
we talking about
uh dark knight rises uh batman in the
theater phones atmosphere tone doom well
i think i think with a a longer movie
like this is that people really want to
be immersed yeah and because they're
like we're here for three hours it
better be fun yeah we were
all righty cool
that's uh moises
let me finish a thought i hope my mic's
okay uh moises sombrano batman movie is
good but superman is way better than
batman batman run away like a little
girl of doom's day i see batman i seen
all batman in superman's movies
you know what that's poisonous
that's fair i don't know what to do
batman is a [ __ ] compared to an alien
who gets power-ups from the sun that's a
hilarious cop batman man and cowboy
alien that's great you know thank you
it's good thank you moises uh john so
some of you guys in the chat actually
had some uh people on their phones i'm
sorry guys
in our imac screening there was a guy on
his phone directly in front of me oh
really i didn't see that yeah yeah
it was it wasn't a ton but he did pull
it up the guy richie
i don't know i tell people he was the
most excited guy he was the one who was
screaming like patton said he's gonna be
here and then he lost his mind when pat
and says oh i heard that guy in the
video i watched the video of you i
watched your video after because i
wasn't physically there but uh what
annoys me in theaters more now is the
[ __ ] watch everyone's got these
goddamn apple watches and then the thing
is no one seems to know like they're so
used to having it they don't notice
their favorite notifications around
light just goes off and then like every
10 minutes yeah well just cover it just
or take it off and put it i put mine
upside down for the movie yeah please
just do that because
and i get it when you're trying to find
your seat but you know like the led
phone light just is a beacon throughout
the entire theater it's gonna escalate
now it's like you walk in with a [ __ ]
escalator yeah like a torch josh g you
see the ventriloquist easter egg in the
beginning koi this is the coyote it's
not josh g what are you referring to
he's talking about uh i actually i did
not detect any ventriloquist you know
mel gibson i'll be a good friend like a
little puppet like crazy [ __ ] [ __ ]
crazy beard love that justice for
melbourne this is for melbourne
is about fantastic milkshakes
and all the super chats of stuff not
only have we name-dropped christielia
here in his life oh [ __ ]
we can get louis ck in here let's do it
i think joe roger should be clay face
just do it tm
trademark
tom maroney uh hi guys
i love y'all and the movie i'm glad
we're up to par with the movie uh knew
this movie would be great uh when
shapiro bitched about it
after the shitty people we just
mentioned
you know i
don't even know what he said but he
literally like tweeted out like sorry to
say guys the batman sucked and then just
a series of tweets yeah because a bunch
of white dudes are monsters because a
bunch of white dudes are monsters i got
some [ __ ] dude on on tick tock was
like i really enjoyed the batman until
it got all woke and i genuinely and this
is the first time that i genuinely had
no idea what he was referring to so i
was like hey man i usually don't talk to
people that unironically use the word
woke but what are you talking about and
he was like well the three
black leads were good and a bunch of
white people were bad and i was like are
you saying that politicians generally
are corrupt and white people are
generally politicians and therefore
white people are generally [ __ ] uh and
like it was just this weird like i
didn't actually see it as woke because
it's just our reality until we fix [ __ ]
movies are gonna have to reflect it and
until we fix it movies are gonna have to
like art has to reflect life so until
white cranky old ass politicians stop
[ __ ] with women and people of color's
lives the movies have to reflect that so
[ __ ] everyone that has that problem with
the film because it's real well i think
what was really triggering
is the
when the the first time i watched it i
was like huh it's probably gonna be
prompted back for people and then i
forgot all about it and the second time
i watched it i was like ah
i need to remember that because it's
probably gonna be problematic for people
when they watch it
you forget again it was when when
catwoman and then sure enough it just
started happening uh like i saw it all
that's on social media it was even the
line about like these white privileged
people
and and to me i was like i'm so into
that scene because i'm like she obvi she
knows batman so well she's like you're
probably rich
he uses the word choice and you don't
have a choice when you're not rich yeah
like it's such a good line she said
white
privilege instead of privileged people
but she added the word
what with a strong w woah
[Music]
why
brady we love you thank you for your
generous contribution today what up guys
been waiting for this as we i loved more
than anything how imperfect batman was
because he was still in his infancy as
the world's greatest detective i wanted
to know what your guys thoughts were
i think it creeps up on you because you
think when they say like year two you're
like oh he's more experienced right he's
more experienced than year one he's been
out of hurry for a year
but what i thought was interesting was
they don't give you backstory i mean i
know there's a prequel novel and i
haven't read the prequel novel nor do i
know the details of what's in it um but
i think for a movie it's really
interesting that they don't give you any
real specifics as to how he kind of was
like kind of like how batman 89 is uh
where you don't know like how do you
hey get this good like where did he
where'd he learn all this i was smarter
in every cop you know how come now one
cop can figure out one riddle
and he's always just like justice
i mean i feel like the lion share the
cops were like wanting it to like they
were dirty so i i like the cops being
like i don't give a [ __ ] about my job
like nobody wants something
i really like that they use some of the
more modern detective technology like
the contacts that's from like a scott
snyder run of memory serves which is
fairly recent like eight years ago and
they also mixed in the you know the
classic frank miller year one stuff but
it all allowed the intelligence of
batman and that's why i think the
riddler was such a great first villain
is you know with with the nolan trilogy
you give us a psychological trilogy
you've got um you know razal ghul and
the idea of capitalism being thing you
have to run an underbrush of fire
through and you've got scarecrow with
the literal psychology and then the
second one that the line in the sand
between joker and batman and the third
and two phase obviously mirroring the
psychology of batman very very linearly
and then bane representing the the other
side of the league of shadows with like
what the city would be under a fascist
rule and like all those things are very
psychological and very um uh
socio-economical but they never once
said privileged white
but peop one is more about like you know
the the actual intelligence of the bat
like you've got someone that's making
riddles that is literally the mirror to
batman there is no one in this universe
so far quite like the parallel between
riddler and bruce wayne like they're
both orphans they're both using their
intelligence to cause a shift and i
really like that they established the
riddler as the first villain because now
we've got a detective series so i agree
with what you're saying but this was
much longer than you probably i think
what was cool is that i like when you
captured even like batman begins i like
when you capture the messiness of his
first of being uh not as experienced
yeah um because like as a detective in
here you know he is like investigating
and being smarter than a lot of the
people around him
but uh when he's a fighter he's just
like the goddamn terminator you know
yeah he's just like let me just march in
and get shot
you know let me just get hit a few times
it doesn't matter i'm just going for it
whereas i feel like batman eventually
has to be a more strategic fighter
instead of just a direct you know
brawler right away you know not
everyone's going to be a bunch of street
folks at a train station at some point
he's got to learn an exposed face man
you can't just walk through hallways all
the
holy time that hallway scene in context
it is so sexy it is interesting how like
when you watch the trailers for this
movie there are certain moments in the
trailer that are like fist bump moments
and they just they kind of read
different in the actual movie where
they're still cool it's more shocking
but you're still like paying attention
yeah you're not like in the movie you're
like you're not cheering you're just
like afraid yeah you're still just
watching it yeah so it's interesting
absolutely quentin marcus where are you
on an episode of always sunny
stay rad
coy and i were both on it's always sunny
we did great work in season seven we are
a great guy
young mac and young dad it's the phone
right
that's right we did
and then koi doubled for mcpoyle at one
point yeah you know me and jimmy simpson
just became tweeted for a little while
absolutely he's in the first episode in
fact
i think first the first season because i
sent you a bunch of pictures because i
was like middle of a run of that show
and i was like greg cause i didn't know
cause he's more humble than me if i'm in
a movie you [ __ ] know it i would love
to go i would love to get back into
acting just to guest star on that show
before i could just do that if i'm like
i'm back in acting hey guys
so go ahead and tag me in for season 16.
manuel rodriguez other than long
halloween and year one what other big
comic animated references koi
this has a lot of bat cat dna the entire
um sunset sequences that is the lighting
and coloring of the artist clayman who's
doing bat cat tom king and clayman's bat
cat that is largely mirroring that
i also think
it is a beautiful parallel to batman ego
psychologically there's a lot of
dialogue that's from batman ego either
directly or of psychology and uh there's
also a really good amount of stuff from
year zero a lot of the flooding a lot of
those things are from scott snyder's
years you're on as well as the
motorcycles so um those are the big five
and those are actually i made a video in
february of what to read first and then
like it was like clockwork of everything
that that ended up popping up which made
me really happy well i think it was also
a hush for sure especially with like
batman and kenneth
and then the brother involvement there's
also earth one right there's a little
earth one especially with the martha
stuff like martha arkham like i thought
that was a great nod to flashpoint
actually because martha ends up being
crazy in the in the flashpoint storyline
thomas wayne becomes batman because his
son is killed and it leads to thomas
wayne being batman and martha being
joker and her going insane and i thought
that was a fun not dumb way to have that
nod of her mental instability also it
sets up a great like batman's a little
[ __ ] crazy because batman's mentally
ill i like that you know sometimes
mentally ill um traits are genetic so i
like that martha being in and out of
asylum gave us that little flashpoint
nod an arkham history a reasoning for
batman's craziness like it gave us a lot
so you're saying if you're mentally ill
you could become batman
that's what i'm saying that's one of the
reasons saying if you have autism you
can become an accountant hit man the
thing about being on a loss
except for in the movement
elif bay rosley oh you're so generous by
the way i've been looking forward to
this movie for the past two years and
watching campia's and your coverage of
everything batman keep up the good work
guys you keep can't be out of this
goddamn conversation you hear me check
his dick
robert pattinson's dick the lighting on
his dick was more of a two-face no i'm
just joking
he's
can't be as my buddy he shouts me out
all the time on his show now i mean we
shot him up too look at him
they put me in their spider-man reaction
i was flattered [ __ ] yeah
i've never been quoted on that show and
they won't quote me every year
everyone's spending their super chats
with us right now until champion goes
live today is what's happening
big sunday big sunday nerd he goes
through the questions faster than us
though the movie uh thank you nerd
collision the movie made me feel as
though i was watching michael keaton's
batman for the first time exciting
amazing and breathtaking
you know
i did want to save this for a separate
video but
he is my favorite batman
michael keaton
michael keaton
right now i'm going to talk [ __ ] about
this batman you know what i did finish
last night because i couldn't sleep was
the founder that was a good movie i love
the founder yeah maybe you really
consider getting back into business
all right i think i got all the wrong
lessons i definitely think you did
because everybody's about corruption but
if greg's over here like ah buying a
home and turning into a mcdonald's
the uh
the the the yeah i think i think robert
pattinson is definitely probably my like
in terms of i i would not say is my
favorite bruce wayne i mean he needs a
little bit more moves for me to call it
that but in terms of batman
see the thing is i'd still be like i
think ben affleck's batman could kick
his ass but he's still not but i still
think that robert pattinson's batman is
my favorite rubber pattern is my
favorite batman pretty comfortably the
amount he was doing with his eyes like
the amount of empathy sympathy vengeance
compassion rage confusion sadness like
there were so many moments where just
robert pattinson's eyes were a better
[ __ ] acting performance i've seen
another [ __ ] i think the thing that rob
hansen has is he's so versatile like if
you guys watch movies like lighthouse or
a good time the guy can carry the guy
has he can do dialogue really [ __ ]
well yeah he's an amazing actor and i
think it would be cool
to see a natural transgression versus or
transition
versus like a studio note b like people
kind of complain about the fact he
wasn't talking make him talk a lot you
know but do it in a natural way where
you see him intent like i would imagine
especially if they do end up introducing
quarter owls that he would have to adopt
the bruce wayne personality and put put
on the smiles and stuff because bruce
wayne can get access to [ __ ] that
[ __ ] batman probably can't get access
to but as bruce wayne you know you can
meet the right people get into the right
groups or something you know yeah be
undercover so i i think you would have
to adapt adopt that and robert pattinson
can't do that like i think i don't think
it would be a challenge it just makes
him cosmopolitan like i actually i was
saying people that want the bruce wayne
need to watch cosmopolis because the
batman doesn't need the bruce wayne yeah
he's he can he's amazing actor man he's
[ __ ] incredible also they call the
next one the caped crusader i think it'd
be cool if they changed the titles like
to the batman the kids that way no one
could ever have their own franchise yeah
you could call a different one the
batman series i've always wanted to do
uh the dark detective series like if i
made a batman movie
get on it greg start detective what are
you doing
my current batman i'm letting other
people make battles
my batman movie is just before sunrise
with batman and catwoman uh moises
thank you koi ready for that give me
that tagline romance unmasked oh [ __ ]
and by the time they get to before
midnight we have the
more elder looking back on their
exploits you can have some flashbacks of
vigilantism yeah they meet up on a
rooftop every night
whether it was the beach or the rooftop
yeah oh oh give me that series oh tom
kagame call you we're gonna make this
green light moistus sombrano i am in
marvel
and dc how do you do it uh so basically
i really
i'm a marvel ndc fan
so basically
i really don't like batman i'm a
superman and spider-man fan superman
beat batman
he's kind of confused but i'm glad you
could get your opinion out there and i'm
just happy you could express yourself
today you know that's uh it takes a lot
to
stand up against a whole crowd of people
raving about batman right now yeah this
is a bold place to say it's a bold place
man i'm proud of you dude you are the
riddler in this chat but it's a safe
space nonetheless
thank you dark jedi knight do you think
that the sequel will give us the court
of owls i want to see the talons done
right also i need to see the catwoman
come back i think catwoman's definitely
coming back i want a solo movie though
first man yeah i really want to see her
in bloodhaven and like you know hinting
at the world they're gonna give night
night wing and also like i wanted to
settle into the alley town oh robin
i think we can take some time that
orphan the the the mayor's kids gonna be
yeah
that could have crowbar written all over
him dude i think i think it works it
could work
yeah i think it could work because there
was definitely a connection to both
bruce wayne bruce wayne and batman and
he was dressed in red the first time we
see him that's true dressed as a ninja
man
i i want
shadows that's right he's the red hood
[Laughter]
if this was a marvel movie you know
there'd being 18 videos about like he
had a presentation
as a marvel fan he had a red hood on uh
but i do think uh the court of alas and
the talons be a really great escalation
i would personally set that up for the
third movie and i would have a little
bit more i want the court of owls to be
just as it was in the comics this big
reveal of oh my god gotham
yeah and i feel like if you set some
eggs easter in the next film uh to hatch
in the third would be the way to do it
so i'd love that person some damn good
egg metaphor dialogue
i actually used a comma in verbal you
hear that little looking
crack that egg open and find out that
they've been spilling their yolk all
over gotham city you know
it's no yolk man
so the uh a-plus
part of me does wonder like what if they
fed ridler some information like how did
ridley how did that how did he know the
details of the renewal oh yeah what was
his uh well he's a he they said he's a
forensic accountant which means he goes
through all the numbers and all those
but he can find out all those details
he's also a professional video editor
too yeah
he outsources that to one of his
followers
does anyone know how
don't worry about it
yeah
did we i thought there was something to
follow up on there talon quarterbacks
the annoying renter hey guys what's the
the 500 mexican oh thank you so much hey
guys there's a mexican with five hundred
dollars
and i just gotta know something about
the batman
what if the next movie uses in no man's
land thank you by the way what if the
next movie uses a no man's land approach
to level up the rogues to comic book
level introduce mr freeze via a heart of
ice storyline intro the court of owls
maybe tease the joker for a third entry
in reeves we trust literally what i want
like you just described everything i
want i'm on joker later and i want mr
freeze next i want a long form quote yes
i agree with you the annoying rancher
well matt reeves said something that uh
rare that we just learned yesterday was
that
a writ there was a scene that would bear
which i think if this scene was in the
movie
everything all right oh
i think oh i think the camera's gonna
cut guys i'm just gonna hit record here
really quick and then i'm gonna stop
recording
b-roll for us later in the future when
i'm like oh [ __ ] we need to expand out
this take or some dumb joke all right so
the um yeah i think what he was saying
was that originally they had a scene
where
batman goes to the joker to ask for help
it's kind of like a clarice and hannibal
moment for him which i think would be
really cool since there are signs of the
lamb's inspirations in this film
and i i actually think if that scene was
in this movie that others the other
scene would have worked way better not
been like they just tacked this on for
sequel purposes you know it actually
would have worked uh a lot stronger and
i think actually having joker in there
like kind of getting to know i like the
idea of building up the way how they did
penguin yeah penguin's like the prime
example here where he's
penguin's not that much screen time
but he still feels like he had a a an
impact because this movie's three hours
so in like a two hour movie would feel
like he was only there for 10 minutes
yeah in a three hour movie you can get
him there for like 30 minutes and it
feels like he's got a decent amount of
screen time right and i think that's
what you should do with some of your
other villains here as you're building
them up when you got you got the penguin
show you've also got this apparently
like arkham slash police show i thought
it was three shows apparently it's two
shows because the arkham cop show and
personally as someone who who sees most
of our television as propaganda i'm
really excited to see a arkham show
mirroring the two mad houses of gotham
you've got the corrupt cops and the
insane that are legally declared insane
and people just described to be cops
like i think that'd be a really
interesting dichotomy of show um so i
think that's how you introduce so many
villains and give them the long form
take like you did with penguin letting
them have little little sins sprinkled
without to build that arkham universe
out um so yeah i love this approach and
i do think the joker um that extra scene
will really help the film because one of
the only scenes i don't like is a joker
scene it's not barry's fault it's just
it felt like it was studio note yeah
felt like well you gotta at least keep
this one see yeah
yeah you hired mary cogan yeah well you
could have just really cut to the
riddler devastated yeah and just dealing
with that and it could just end it there
especially with how moody it is like
watching him feel like a failure yeah
you know and and watching yeah that be
like the sort of modus like the the
inspiration for him to come back bigger
and better because i'm sure i i prefer
the juxtaposition there where in a lot
of ways riddler did win like in more
ways than one riddler destroyed gotham
he destroyed gotham yeah and now he's
smart and the whole thing they just
followed his path even when they thought
they were a step ahead of him yeah they
were all he was always ahead and then
won like riddler won this movie yeah but
these but with the way but riddler won
yet riddler feels like he lost because
he didn't get the batman and so i i
would love i wish you just ended on that
juxtaposition with the two yeah and i
think that would have been more poignant
lily aguilera hey lily hello real reject
and coy
that's
that's greg and coy
yeah you don't mention you rejects and
yeah john john
and
john and tech monkey
what was the one scene that left you
speechless mine was the scene with
batman and riddler love all you guys
first of all i want to acknowledge that
there is only one scene with batman and
ridler and that's cool i really like
that you you listed this because when
you look at the movie you're like oh
yeah batman fighting riddler there's no
physical fight because he's a mental
villain which i really enjoyed that that
not comic book take and that scene was
incredible uh for me it was i cannot get
over the first introduction of the
batmobile in this universe like when
they when they cut to that car and it
just turns on like a demon and like that
entire chase sequence we've seen a
thousand chase sequences that movie it
uses this really simple but obvious and
honest and great technique of penguin is
usually shot over the shoulder so you
feel like you're being pursued by batman
so you get the paranoia of the penguin
you also get some great reaction shots
you get to feel the fear of the batman
but then with batman you're usually
behind the car shot so you feel like
you're the one pursuing so you you
subconsciously feel like you are batman
in those shots and then you feel like
you're being chased when you're penguin
so that car chase reinvents a very
obvious choice but does it in a comic
book cinema and and that plus the roar
of the batmobile like that whole
sequence had me [ __ ] hard
yeah
it was really uncomfortable sitting next
to me i know i was like bro bro look at
this [ __ ] batmobile that's what i call
them now
let's rev this engine
[Laughter]
barracuda
[Laughter]
give me one sec guys i think
i think i was like
this this is an odd moment i think to
pull but for whatever reason i i was
left kind of speechless after the moment
where he
right as gordon pulls him off that guy
in the catwalk when he injects himself
with the adrenaline and he's just
unleashing all of the pain and rage and
even catwoman is like whoa dude that you
trying to calm me down
and
even though that's not like the biggest
most picturesque moment in the movie
that was a moment where when he turns
around and he's got that wild look on
his face like he could have decked
gordon if you didn't have that one
little ounce of restraint like that that
left me pretty speechless in the moment
i got a confession to make about that
scene
you don't like that scene i actually
love that scene it's one of my favorites
but when he turns around
as i
i always think of the batman from how it
should have ended
[Laughter]
right now i'll still be speechless for
other reasons
oh he's so good
because i'm batman
it's like a mix of will or net and how
it
should have been it is pretty much so
we'll earn it
we are not caught up we're not no we're
about to refresh our friends
go to the stream yeah
pull up the live chat here on the phone
uh really quick uh hey in the chat in
the live chat somebody uh victor manav
wants to know what's your favorite
riddle
what's your favorite did you have a
favorite riddle out of the movie uh out
of the different riddler rhythms like
the first one he lied still is pretty
great like because it's just the the the
layers in the answers you know what i've
seen it three times and it's my favorite
one and i remember some of the other
ones too they're not coming to mind
right now
[Laughter]
that is a good first clever because i
like the layers of eli still like even
after death and also he's physically
still like i like a good pun i like a
good pun riddles that one's my favorite
you know what's weird this isn't good
it's not really a riddle but for
whatever reason see you in hell
really uh
like unfolded in my mind because i was
like that means so many things i see you
right now in hell beholding what's
happened to alfred i will see you in
hell when i am in prison yeah i also see
you in hell as the city but like there's
a lot of people think that's bane venom
yeah venom
yeah the early stages for it yeah i i
could see that but i also don't know how
much bane would work in this yet so i
don't know if they literally work
of course darth knight rises you can
work here i love bane i just want him
smarter than that dark knight rises bane
is not bane from the cops no no no but i
think it i i think you just need a
smarter than bruce bane and i think you
you could get there
bruce bane uh i think one more movie
until till dane i'm going to mexico
pandemic jones thank you buddy good to
see you absolutely yeah thank you
pandemic uh yeah i can't wait for the
pitch meetings i was just looking at
stuff from you guys chat i absolutely
loved this movie the cinematography and
music was amazing my favorite sequences
were the car chase gill bomb and riddler
talking to batman in prison also loved
that they focus on the detective batman
what were your favorite mementos
well i already say my favorite sequence
so
what would you say when you re-watch
this
what are you like waiting for what
i'd love i really love like i think if i
had to nail down like a see a scene that
i just love it is
it is the whole thing at the police
station there's something about that the
way the way gordon and him are talking
and he's just like doing this
downstairs
yeah when the cops like i'll get you a
charge for assaulting officer three
you can't even count yeah i also love
like his moonlighting as a cub
and i love that little smile he get that
when batman smiles that little i think
you got that jawline there yeah yeah
there's like something there's something
like so cool about that because he never
smiles and he does it's awesome i caught
the most smiles on the third viewing
yeah there was someone said he never
smiles i'm like he does they're just
very subtle yeah uh i think the the
fight between catwoman and batman when
he like drops down and pretty good at
that and like it's just so catwoman like
the way she's breaking into that like
all of her
physicality and the way they fight just
feels so like [ __ ] sexy like i love
the bat in the cat so that that sequence
really worked for me
good call
i'm gonna give some love to alfred and
bruce in the hospital quality acting
cause uh yeah like just the way that i
almost like the third time i was just
sitting there going just tell him you
love him bruce just tell me to say i
love you
i know he's not gonna but i want him to
real bad and yeah for whatever reason
here in this moment because you we've
talked about so many of the other iconic
wonderful beautiful moments and uh aside
from like the opening of the movie at
the very ending of the movie that's
that's another one that certainly stands
out
i do i really like the choice of bruce
in this movie a lot uh i do think though
i have a hard time
there's this like dark night of the soul
moment uh
after alfred dies and he's learning the
truth about his folks that's what bruce
wayne calls his parents this is my folks
so he's learning the truth about
his parents and he seems like all
devastated after he talks to carmine
falcone i have a hard time
feeling like i i think broad path is
doing a great job acting
but as a viewer i don't really
feel the devastation with him or for him
because
like i don't this movie does no
flashbacks and he doesn't do any talking
at all about you know his relationship
with thomas wayne so really all i have
to work off of is you know my prior
knowledge of batman moving into this
movie
so
it's weird because in that scene that
you're talking about
i don't really connect with bruce but i
reconnect the i connect so much with
alfred and i and like he brings me to
tears in that scene like he's such a
it's such a uh such a great moment for
him when you're you're seeing how much
this guy's sacrificing how he just feels
like he sucks up doing what he's doing
and now he has this feeling of you know
like the last thing he'd want is for
bruce to look down on his parents when
they sacrificed everything for him and
they and probably cost their lives
because he was trying to protect them
you know so i love alfred's perform i
love annie circus performance in that
moment but i do
feel like i could have used like
one thing of him talking about
you know his parents in some way we
don't need to see the pearls and the
alleyway shot or anything like that i'm
glad there were no flashbacks though
because i like that i like that
like goes in the mansion and that whole
like super emo moment when he goes into
like the way uh
his parents
like i'm not really for so every time i
watch it i don't really feel much when
i'm watching it all right but yeah i
yeah also shouts out to when bruce shows
up to uh when bruce himself shows up to
the club oh that's so great and that
one-two punch of uh like because he does
like a haymaker uppercut combo and drops
that dude yeah but i like the transition
when he's going through the crowd or
everyone's just looking at him and he
doesn't give a [ __ ] he's just wet and
this imposing thing and then he goes to
the black and the red flashing no he's
at the dancing hello yeah well that but
also when he shows up to talk
yeah to karma when he just shows up and
he's like you know who i am and
tweedledee and tweedledum are like
yeah i know who you are yeah dude also
tweedledeems feel dumb shout out i love
that we got like a solid carver twins
john daniel there's a moment early on
where bruce gets out of his car at
pete's funeral and
the and sneers at the paparazzi and i'm
convinced that pattinson did that
instinctively i mean [ __ ] the paparazzi
yeah [ __ ] the paps bruh
our pat says [ __ ] that did he really
sneeze
i think what some people want is um bad
bruce wayne to be just so into the alter
ego personality that it affects his
batman work
like he he's just like parties way too
much
batman he's
i need electrolytes
hi all greg would your cats get along
with zoe kravitz's catwoman good
question and what did y'all think of the
catwoman compared to the others have uh
a good day
it is the most batman year one ever our
cats would get along with cat one cause
cats are feelers more than anything else
and um
just like all animals really i think boy
cats especially are just all about
feeling
and yeah absolutely uh her catwoman i
think i i still
you know it's been
i don't want to know if it's nostalgia
i think it's still michelle pfeiffer for
me
it's hard to beat hello there
michelle pfeiffer could only exist in
the tim burton universe and zoe could
only exist in this universe so it's
really hard for me because
especially compare compare
make the choice make the choice no but
like i think out of anyone next to
batman like catwoman is a product of
gotham right so i feel like the manic
insane energy of michelle pfeiffer is
the most like cinematic and big and bold
cell so our first also that outfit like
there's so many things that make that
iconic but that would only work at the
cranked up to not even 11 but 14 gotham
that is tim burton's universe so i think
the reason people might like not like
this one as much as that one one first
introduction but also she has to be more
real she has to be more grounded she has
to operate both as selena and catwoman
she has her mask off more than anyone so
i think the i thought zoe kravitz's
backstory was that she died but cats
brought her back oh yeah no no that was
the cutscene
that was the joker the joker has to
explain the batman he's like you know
your girlfriend got eaten by cats
um but no that died so i feel like zoe
kravitz like she had to do a more
subdued thing so i loved this catwoman
personally but i also can't separate my
insatiable crush on zoe kravitz so she
is she's in my phone background for you
this movie brought me around to her yeah
yeah i absolutely adored her performance
in this movie whenever john saw her
before he'd always be like [ __ ] some
correctness no it's the thing it's it's
one of the every now and again an actor
arrives skips fury road scenes he's like
[ __ ] no no no no no no it's it's it's
that thing like i had a similar thing
with chalamet and and and i'm still
bridging that gap to a degree where i'm
like
you're perfectly fine i i think you're
good but i just don't connect with you
for some reason have you seen them [ __ ]
a peach i haven't and i wonder
i wonder if that's what changes you once
you see them actually funny enough
french dispatch is the movie i've liked
him in the most so far aside from dune
because dune he's like perfectly cast
for that um but yes this one this movie
totally endeared me to zooey kravitz
anyhow certainly interrupted that
but yeah so i think zoe kravitz's like
oh check out kimmy too kimmy's really
good see the subway's new movie yeah
i've been uh i've been hearing about
that bubblegum
thank you for asking your job today is
to give the right look so that way these
two know like you know we're
gonna be here forever and i'm trying not
to avoid that before you guys are
crashing and i'm like see that
that was interesting
curtis mason i just finally saw the
batman last night with my dad i am so
glad i saw this in theaters this was my
first dc film watched in theaters since
man of steel what a spectacular first
one says man of steel good one a lot of
dc movies you were like [ __ ] that opted
out what a spectacular experience and i
loved the movie so much uh druid as
joker is gonna be dope
so first of all curtis mason is one of
my patrons he's an exceptional human
being second of all i don't know how
much more druid as joker we're gonna get
i have a feeling it might not be
a bit until the third one uh and thirdly
uh bird of birds of prey is pretty dope
man bird's parade's uh worth checking up
i like bob the bop is a bop
ah i'm glad you like me i'm glad you're
with me greg sitting here like man the
energy no man no no eventually you guys
will crash and then i'm gonna yeah an
hour three of these when i step in and
go it's my turn
i reserve i i i've learned in these
streams because before when we do these
streams i would be so high so up there
and then i realized i gotta take a
breather yeah because we might be here a
while
and i hate when we're like i'm just dead
sometimes i facetime in and i've already
left i
am crashed at all times
thanks curtis pattinson hates being
called our pat's coy yeah yeah [ __ ] the
disrespect [ __ ] i love it
i loved the movie and saw it twice i do
appreciate you coy calling out the
criticisms that just aren't fair i'm
intrigued by the batman joker deleted
scene after uh set after the
commissioner's death yeah this movie's
perfect there's nothing wrong with this
movie every moment is perfect there's
nothing wrong with it
we got more from dan v uh the brother
revealing joker in november was
disappointing uh wish i didn't know
going in hush is going to uh
hush is being set up and reeves said he
wants to use him people claiming he only
called himself vengeance are wrong he
says this could be the end of the batman
to gordon i feel like that detail is
left with a bit of ambiguity i feel like
he is toying with being called vengeance
but also aware that everyone calls him
the batman
and is probably conscientious enough to
know that you don't always choose your
nickname i also like the idea that like
he sees himself as a force of nature
until he acknowledges he has to be a
symbol like the batman symbol metaphor
is the entire dark knight trilogy and
the moment in the movie where the the
riddler
like you know lackey says i'm vengeance
is him realizing his symbol's been
stolen and how that is a negative and
how vengeance isn't always a positive
like beautiful way to do the entire
nolan trilogy like summarized in a
moment but i do think him acknowledging
the batman as a symbol is going to be a
really great arc in a different way in
this universe because of that like the
disparity you're talking about i'm just
saying this bruce wayne better be doing
loads of cocaine though lots of below
appearances very important that's what's
most important
dan v again and alfred's like you better
keep up appearances he's like get the
hookers alfred
call my dealer outfit
he talks to alfred in the bathroom wait
associates are coming here where are my
benzos out there
now got an equation for him to just get
so reactionary the way wb can be
[Music]
crawling on his face to the batmobile
they just realized
that
they call it the bruce yeah they're just
cg
that should be that should be the sequel
is him struggling
to balance his party life
addiction
this is way harder this is way harder
than crime i just love the juice
and then people are going to be like
bruce wayne was never this much of a
party yeah
too much playable so much public
personality he wouldn't buy the entire
russian opera boat damn what happened oh
he did that's right yeah with the
ballerinas and everything good because
that way he stole aaron aircraft date
night but he also had an alibi double
bruce wayne double the fun double bruce
dan v two more from danvy now i don't
want joker in the sequel since it still
feels early dan we're on the same page
reeves explained his take on the joker
where he's not joker yet and he's and uh
he has a smiling condition different
from joaquin phoenix's laughing
condition but batman put him in prison
already
is interesting i'm looking forward to
the deleted scene and then dan goes on
to say the entire cast crushed it i said
it after good time that pattinson could
be batman i said i wanted paul dayno as
the riddler for years remember when
jonah hill was cast as riddler but
dropped out due to money dano then being
cast made my day he nailed it i remember
the jonah hill thing that'd be really
interesting now having seen the film
because i think he would have leaned
more into the online persona i think we
would have seen a bit more of that like
trolling like leaning into like i'm
what's black and white it dead all over
yeah because like jonah's an incredible
actor i just think that would have been
more of an element to it because paul
dano's got that operatic literally in
this case big theatricality that that
philip seymour hoffman acting whereas
jonah hill has a more subdued snark yeah
flev
flavius doran hi guys i was really
impressed by the film being a more
detective story and all my mistake
was that i watched it at 11 00 p.m
11 p.m screening when i uh was a jockey
highlighted yes sir when i was very
tired so my enjoyment was affected
uh by it hope to watch it again at a
decent hour after i have had time to die
i'm out at 2 a.m i don't i don't blame
you like for a movie
i'm sorry no man do your thing
just pee in the chair
when uh for what does that mean for a
movie like that
to be three hours long and start at 11
o'clock
and especially when it's your first time
where you're truly not prepared for the
kind of pacing it is i think that's i
think that's like the main thing is that
i think the pacing is great
at the same time i don't think a lot of
people are properly prepped for the
pacing of the movie absolutely the movie
the trailers
leave a different impression
as if that like the pacing will be much
quicker yeah and there will be a lot
more like crazy picturesque actions i
could see if you go in tired you could
fall asleep to this movie yeah and i
wouldn't be like you suck you don't like
movies enough bang bang for you yeah i'd
be like no i get it i i'd fall asleep
yeah i totally understand although it's
maybe it's maybe it's the benefit of the
times in which we have seen it is every
time we've seen it i think both of us
have been pretty sleep deprived and
luckily not yet i've yet to fall asleep
during the batman so uh that's the path
that's the power of quality cinema
monkey in the chat danny devito or colin
farrell who did it better danny devito
did it more
i think we'll need to see uh what else
colin farrell grows into
well i don't think it's a fair
comparison because like penguin the the
burden verse
is so fantastical it's like so
fantastical
like jack nicholson falls into a vat of
toxic chemicals it comes out with
perfect clown makeup
you know on his face and then has to
paint his face normally yeah yeah
penguin who like
was raised with penguins and it was like
a penguin yeah
and
yeah he's like way more of like a
creature yeah and catwoman was
resurrected by cats mm-hmm
you know and
cat zombies so like it's it's silly it's
much sillier uh so i don't think like
they're so different whereas
i think penguin and this one
is more
uh al capone
versus danny devito's
which is like
human penguin
and i really adore them both for being
able to bring such a natural
quality to such an outlandish character
both times like danny devito like you
forget you think of dan devito and you
think of like it's always sunny and
stuff like that but you forget like oh
he could really act and like really sell
an outlandish character like that and
then and then colin farrell on the other
end is like chameleon total
transformation you know
oh yeah thanks
any sign any time
leaving the space for koi for just
tuning in yeah pandemic jones pdj did
you guys have any nitpicks with the
movie yeah i felt like the bat and the
catwoman romance came out of nowhere
unexpected yes love them together though
lol what did you guys think of
everyone's portrayal more specifically
pattinson is batman i think he's my fave
i i think that we need some a little bit
of more time with his bruce wayne for me
to really narrow it down because i do
think it's a part of batman that he has
to eventually do the dual personality
like i think it's a part of his
character um but in terms of a nitpick
my only real
nitpick is
when he's uh doing the back
wing suit
i think that is some pretty awful cgi it
looks like daddy's home when mark
wahlberg is skateboarding
they're like bobble heads that like
looks like a kind of like we attached
his head on some
it looks like a green screen thing like
i could go to some event and they could
put my head on top of his head or
something like that i don't think that
that wing suit looks that good
weirdly on imax it looks all right
yeah yeah
because you're like overwhelmed yeah and
people applaud it after that yeah the
first time i heard the applause yeah
first yeah but when we saw it the first
time yeah oh i was like oh that is not
look good yeah well and yeah the nature
of the shot itself doesn't help whatever
cg embellishments they had to do because
it's already kind of a funky looking
thing when you're locked on his head and
his body is moving independently of that
yeah it looks sick and that's how it
looks in real life when you do one of
those headlock games but with the movie
being so grounded it was like what a
strange turn yeah uh my only nitpick is
the uh i think the joker scene should
have been post credit i have a nitpick
no you just keep you on all right i'm
doing a live stream i got a couple small
nitpicks one
uh when did he go back and swim around
for his knife oh thanks man uh because
he clearly dropped it when he fell off
the cable all right he's got a couple
probably transferred to uh transfer the
50 000 and uh other nitpick and it's not
really he's finally paying nitpick oh
yeah koi is the decade they find it
really hard to get before tourist
studios
you hear me
[ __ ] hear me
this moment in the livestream i'm gonna
need to find this moment again the nip
someone tell us what time stand
it's very lucky that we go over the
scene we should we should play john
campio's live stream
let's get it
[Laughter]
yeah here let's go to cambia right now
i noticed whilst watching the movie this
time it's very lucky that bruce doesn't
have to deal with any of the cops when
the explosion happens at wayne tower
because he's at every crime scene
anywhere there's a to the batman letter
he is summoned and asked to show up in
the movie very conscientiously glosses
entirely past the possibility of that uh
and i was sitting there thinking but
what if they shine the bat signal or
like you know is this the one time
batman's not gonna show up bro gordon's
gonna be like what gives dude
why didn't they try to take off his mask
way earlier yeah too yeah yeah they take
him and take it off and probably
yeah yeah they're mutter about it
they're like man never mind that's it
how do we get it off he should have had
a little zappy thing like a dark knight
i always thought that was clever in dark
knight yeah
yeah i think that was clever um
i think on the wall
even though they leave it ambiguous of
like does ridler actually know he's
batman or not
there's enough where he at least
contemplated it on it was enough to be
on the wall
where
batman was like oh [ __ ] he knows i'm
persuaded yeah you know that's why he
goes to arkham hospital like that and
he's pretty much saying he's goodbye to
gordon in that scene he's like you're a
good cop you know like saying his
goodbye he's like this is the time for
the batman to end like he's he's
accepted it he's looking at the wall
going [ __ ] river figured it out also the
idea that no cop was like
those chins yeah like right next to each
other but that's also a batman nippy
bruce uh campbell bruce wayne flem doran
i was impressed by all performances but
i felt in a batman film batman was the
least outstanding every secondary
character played great but bruce being
the lead i expected a different standard
and it didn't hit for me not to say that
he was bad
i think the batman performed great and i
think bruce we talked about the top of
this wasn't wasn't a lead yet so like
the batman i think was a very
intentional title personally the last
like hour of this movie you don't see
bruce after he leaves the hospital with
alfred i think it's great he's just only
in the batsuit yeah
well and yeah like i can absolutely uh
respect your opinion but i do i do feel
like uh there is something no no you
guys are gonna live in the dark with us
for a while now i was born welcome to
the darkness moulded by it i'm a [ __ ]
i didn't see the camera until i was a
man uh but yeah i do it does seem like
this is the batman movie where the
forefront of the conversation and the
debate is batman before we get to the
other characters in most conversations
i've had and that seems unique to me
even if it's about people not
necessarily loving him as much i feel
like there is something to be said for
the fact that it's at least interesting
and distinct enough that it is often
among the first things people mention
rather than it being the villains and
then well i think that's a full arc
people keep saying he doesn't have an
arc in this movie no
i think what people are missing is that
bruce wayne doesn't really have an ark
it's batman who has an arc that's kind
of the point of like it ends on batman
but and it also ends with he's batman so
bruce would also have the same epiphany
like my issue
bruce doesn't have an ark i'm like guys
bruce is doing the voiceover guys
spoiler bruce wayne is back yeah so when
the voiceover happens that's bruce
having the same identity the arc happens
through his identity as batman and i
think that's great i think that's
beautiful you don't see that usually
it's you know we've seen the [ __ ]
dark knight movies you'd say give some
goddamn monologue right what the theme
is in the lesson and it's usually i am
iron man not i am robert downey jr i am
tony stark like yeah we've seen the
other you know
marwan what was your favorite scene in
the movie mine personally was the whole
fear as a tool opening you see that
whole thing about that opening of why i
love it is i i personally feel like
the did i ever say this in the stream
about the opening we talked about the
bookends but we didn't talk about just
the opening i think i've said that i
think this is the best 15 to 20 minutes
of any batman movie and like the first
thing that pops into mind is better than
the dark knight i think that is a great
joker prologue um i think it's a perfect
that that pro i think it's brilliant
even though there's like some nitpicks
like you mean no one's gonna know the
box was coming it had no one
crashed through this big ass making like
one dusty bus one dusty bus but
but i don't ever think about that funny
enough when i'm watching it but the but
in this like they said the way they set
up the riddler the parallels of the
intro of the actual visual introductions
of seeing riddler and seeing batman and
also the way they introduce batman in
here
more than just pulling straight from
long halloween it just feels like pure
batman like my favorite moment in that
whole thing
is when
they're talking about the shadows and
then you're cutting to the criminals and
they just like it's like that signals up
that feeling that we have with horror
when you're like is that is that there
when he says i am in the shadows i buy
it yeah no they're like panicking
infinity and he's not even there but
they just think he's there and that's
how scared they are of him and it's a
great way to set him up and so i and
that's why it's like you start off that
movie where he's in the dark and then it
ends where he's like in the in the light
with the people you know yeah it's
beautiful it's a [ __ ] arc what i love
i loved it in the prologue too he refers
to it to the crime and criminals just as
the element yeah and at the end he
clarifies criminal element but i just
love that phrasing let's keep going all
right flavius fled more flev uh
all right cool we'll be good here yeah
flavin another marwan uh my favorite dc
villain is deathstroke because of arrow
and titans and so i love the coin
and so i would love to see him in the
next film i don't know how much a
direction he and batman actually had in
the comics but i just want to see a
proper portrayal of the big screen you
know i think you guys see that man's
genitals in the show spartacus the one
who plays deathstroke and arrow oh dude
and there's a comic where you see
batman's dick so we can get them both
naked dicks
people want an r-rated batman so bad
that's how you get there yeah that's how
you do it just hit that back dick
to have replay value this video and now
it's not going to no it doesn't look
like you're
we've done shot ourselves goddamn foot
here people uh deathstroke's a great
character and they were going to do
deathstroke as the main villain in the
batfleck one uh i do think that
inevitably that that stuff will come to
light because
well i i do think it's inevitable
because if you notice a lot of these
studios if they develop a script to a
point they're gonna use some of that
later so i do think with the stuff
coming out of the snyder verse that
they're keeping they will be a death
troop that would piss off so many people
but it's coming but it wouldn't piss off
marwan you know what they should do they
should get ben affleck to direct it
[Laughter]
right yeah
that guy looks like bulked up marwan
what is your favorite scene in the movie
and what are your uh what are your
complaints my personal favorite scene is
the whole fear is a tool monologue
my only comment
is that uh no cop noticed that there was
a connection between bruce wayne and
batman on the wall that was one of my
nitpicks too and i also do feel like the
cops are like pretty apathetic like they
don't really care um except except
martinez i mean martinez which hey
martinez i love you that's a favorite
scene uh
batman's walking through the cops and
he's like a foot taller everybody and
he's just so intimidating and martinez
puts his hand yeah like that's a
favorite scene well and also too the
book end then when he when it's just the
two of them in riddler's apartment he's
finally like all right okay i'll try and
work with you
yeah martinez's arc is great that is
such an enjoyable scene because batman
does nothing
he just left martinez
just lets him oh you know
it's a tool for tucker
when you first see that scene
it seems like he's annoyed with him yeah
yeah he's like put in the light i'm like
stop talking to me
again actually a good tip
did that come from you
i grew up rich i don't have carpet
i don't know how to install it carpet
someone puts this in you want to strap a
rocket onto a barracuda let's do this
and i do like when they reveal the
carpet how it looks awkwardly placed
yeah you're like there is something
strange about this carpet like
carpet bright green yeah it's good
absolute vodka
i'm just gonna catch us up to the super
chats
somebody a monkey in the chat asked us
but you didn't get to weigh in danny
devito or colin farrell who did it
bitter colin farrell for me uh i love
danny devito's
take because it is so otherworldly and
so big but there is a lot of in
discrepancies between like i'm running
for politics because i want to no i
don't and yes this is there's a lot of
like story elements that have to happen
so if you guys hit the like button
before i forget please stop no i was
answering
can you hit the like button and see if i
interrupt you it sounds like it's an
important thing
like excuse me emergency hit the like
button all right koi now please danny
devito felt like he was having to do
things for the sake of the story whereas
colin farrell felt like he led the story
so i like colin farrell's take i also
like a more grounded take on the batman
so for me it's colin farrell pretty
comfortably he stole every scene he was
in and this is a movie of powerhouse
actors so brianna says in the chat
about apparently batman doesn't
understand spanish i believe that i
am going to have a confession here
i did not realize until it was pointed
out to me
that when he goes on to the website
i was like oh url yeah
oh you didn't catch that i was like
yeah how does he know to go on the
website like
everyone i talked to who
knows that yeah i love that because
that has a flow that's completely gone
over my head
every single time it's the only thing
that said slowly like in that whole
sequence u r
l
greg's like w w w
because i just think of it i don't think
of the letter u that's why it's such a
good word i know yeah i know it's i get
it uh but it's
not the world's greatest decision
i was like
i could pick up on all the character
pathos
and read into that
visual complexities but then we say
something like url like how did he know
to go to that website
hacker man
one and uh vaguely tangentially on topic
i just adore that penguin is like you
guys don't speak spanish i'm like do you
speak spanish
spaniel
like
the guy that's going to be dealing with
every person is going to know more than
the guy that's only dealt with the elite
i love that the penguin is like guys i
speak 17 languages yeah there
yeah that's something the penguin's
smart yeah a lot of people need to
remember that because these are the
that's part of penguin's character you
don't become a crime boss accidentally
you look at him and you laugh him off
you think he's a joke that's the big
part of penguin yeah buddy but he's
actually a really smart guy i i really
love the portrayal on the gotham show i
think it's a very underrated show
even people who don't like i've seen
second season no i just i love that the
amount of times gotham's come up in the
last month of my life versus the other
five
years i've seen all of you i've seen all
of gotham i think gotham's i i think uh
especially the second season it really
finds a stride really strong but that's
another reason i think colin farrell
over danny devito answered that question
further is the intelligence of penguin
is beautifully done with colin farrell
yeah
david gandy thank you for the moment of
silence friend david thank you thank you
darling david david's the best miguel
martinez love you david we love you
indefinitely
uh miguel martinez batman or spider-man
what comic book movie did you guys enjoy
the most
the movie i'd want to make is batman
sure yes i put it like that if i was to
watch these two movies i'd go which one
feels like a filmmaker's movie and one
that i'd be like oh i want to make a
movie like that
it's batman
spider-man
is obviously probably much easier to
rewatch and much more of a crowd pleaser
and it's more easter eggs but at the
same time
i mean i don't want to fully say this
because it still has that special
thing of the three of them coming okay
let's like this
i feel like we're going to get more
movies with tommy mcguire and andrew
garfield teamed up if it with tom
holland right yeah we're gonna it's
gonna be it's gonna happen and then by
that point it's like now when you see
the avengers together you're like yeah
it's just the thing let them go versus
like the first time you've seen them
where you're like
they're spinning around six characters i
love
yeah you can put movies together that
impact is gonna like really go down once
we're like oh they're doing it all once
we're used to it yeah once the
spider-verse movie happens it's
inevitable yes where and while i do
think that's a fantastic movie um
this one is more
it's special in a very different way and
it sucks that i instantly knew people
will compare them and it doesn't help
that the same composer did the score for
both these moves
does not get enough credit how do you
pronounce it john gichino i believe it's
jacquino
i think his is twitter yeah the fact
that the fact that michael
j michael
in fact the mg
mgk mgk
batman score
the fact that he is an alpha he has an
omega like he did both of these scores
for the like two sensational combo
movies they're two very different films
it's really impressive man and the
energy of both is reflected in the score
yeah the energy of spider-man is so
different than this and like three
months apart uh i i don't think i can
honestly compare them like i know that
the expression apples and oranges is a
common one but like this to me is like
do i want a burger or do i want a pizza
do i want a a savory steak or do i want
a salad like you don't you don't go for
them for the same purpose so honestly
they're both a's and they're both
exceptional in their field but their
fields are so different that i i cannot
say ones about the other person and
that's saying a lot because i love
spider-man pretty heavy so like for
batman to be as good as just insane but
they're both considered comp movies so
they must be comparable
there are ends of the spectrum for me
they're two polar sides because they're
both like superlatives in their own way
but you know batman is very meticulous
very like tightly crafted whereas
spider-man is pretty loose with its
details and its circumstances but it
really nails the heart and the fun
whereas the batman nails the grit and
the tone and and the deeper themes and
all that stuff like like they're great
polar ends of the spectrum i feel like
can you pin adrian a's comment i was
gonna point that out yeah
yes uh uh uh why does greg look like
rasputin from the king's man in the
thumbnail
uh does that have curly hair not so good
yeah what and also shouts out to the man
gareth hood just popping up in the chat
i haven't seen you in ages my dude we
will get to your super chat 3 000 people
were able to vote which character was
your favorite yeah wear them like where
are the like buttons
we need this to have replay value and
that's how you get it i think
i don't understand youtube
all righty
jones lots of code up in a whopper one
virus effects follow him on the gram he
makes cool prosthetics and and uh
special effects gags and stuff among
other things good artists as well we got
a couple of his paintings up on the wall
batman should vape bat vape never leave
the cave without it
and dude how badass would he look with
just the
just a fatty cloud coming that scene
with the fire extinguisher wasn't
actually it was vape look at this
because dakota jones made that look at
that speaking of deathstroke deathstroke
and we also got homelander up there too
boom hey guys love seeing you all again
the last scene come back here and grab
pictures off the wall do it grab our
displays grab everything uh oh you guys
got that displayed sponsored yeah shouts
out to this display find a recent video
go in the description and save yourself
23 percent on one or two displays or 27
on three or more with our uh special
link oh you got a baby
oh yeah they only got one of those big
ones yet they send you the big ones when
you're sponsored well excuse me display
you got my number i buy from you monthly
i bought one yeah on my own i have 38
because they're cool wow i have a lot of
displays and i have an eight places i
rotate them through so my background's
always different depending on what i'm
talking about i just put up my tupac my
eminem next to my batman once i get a
different sponsor i'm taking them damn
display stamina
the last scene in between you you do
look like randy from christmas card uh
with the blimp uh the last scene between
alfred and bruce had me in tr's and the
car
the [ __ ] car was beautiful also the
way the villains were portrayed as top
notch
i couldn't agree more yeah i'm really
getting like a comfort situation at
least
do you need anything else over there
you want some ear muffs
a little you want a scarf or a sweater a
little little rope
slippers i've been drinking like a
gallon of water a day for like three
weeks how did you not feed and now i'm
just but i haven't drink any water damn
oh
i think i'm starting to feel that effect
yeah dude you got to hydrate man very
important so i've had to pee
love you dakota jones andy
andy b who i'm gonna tell john campbell
andy b who i'm going to pretend is andy
bernard uh do you see the possibility of
seeing selena kyle become the biggest
villain to batman by the end of the
trilogy between
bt dubs love the from belgium
belgium you gotta build the conflict
that's something they don't they have
none of the live actions have really
done
fully yet
where it's like [ __ ]
they're
the one thing that separates them is
catwoman's a [ __ ] thief you know
they just get on the same goddamn page
about stop stealing catwoman you know
yeah then we can just be together
because not even this movie does that
but they they tease some of like the
differences like i don't want to kill
this person but that's it doesn't really
or like she steals some money but then
batman finds out why and he's like oh
i'm sorry
your dad was kind of a prick you deserve
that
you should have that duffel bag of money
you need more i know a guy named bruce
you can probably get some some sort of
donation
the rich aren't exactly spreading the
wealth around this city you see my dad
tried and kind of [ __ ] us up maybe i
should care about the wealth because i
could use that
i also love that they address the whole
like if batman's a billionaire why
doesn't he just put money into gotham
which is a real thing like in life in
human in our life i think that's a
that's a quantifiable thing but i love
the renewal program being like that's
why because like thomas wayne tried to
[ __ ] things up more yeah why don't you
become a billionaire and see if you're
going to give all your money i'd like to
yeah that's what everyone who not a
billionaire says
but us billionaires on youtube jeff
bezos is like a billionaire
jeff bezos's wife is single-handedly
helps slow the rainforest the
deforestation of the rainforest you'll
never make it to a billion if your goal
is to give the billion away i'd like
that yeah i'd like that i would like i'd
like that i'd like that billionaires
here on this channel
born in 1969
a bunch of muted out four tauruses out
there on the streets full of drug money
harley daniel coy
i've been watching you since the early
mmn days what
show i did matt key back in 2016.
[ __ ] mac he's [ __ ] matt key he
looks like pat reeves it's true it's
true yeah
well anyway
since the early mmn days what are the
chances of soups in this universe in
your opinion provided you haven't heard
what matt reeves says i would say
here's why you should be concerned about
the riddler's plan for golfing
cook this send it to me
universe tick-tock
and matthew romney i think that uh
superman should not be in this universe
because that negates a lot of the ground
reality of it i think that
i think that this being the anti-marvel
movie in a lot of ways is the best thing
for comic book movies because this isn't
trying to build a shared universe it's
trying to build its own shared universe
we're getting tv shows we're getting
movies we're building out gotham but
gotham should stay isolated the batman
comics occasionally dabble but detective
comics is largely the bat family the
batman comics are largely batman like if
you go too far shared then you lose this
tone and that specialness so i please to
[ __ ] god don't share this universe
part of me is worried that matt reeves
is gonna
spread himself too thin with the two
shows in the movies two shows there's
like like way more apparently the arkham
show is the gotham show that's what i
figured
a lot of people are forgetting about the
k-pop the cape crusader show the
animated hbo max one that him jj abrams
oh yeah
consulting
he can just say like good he's writing
and directing and hand animating every
episode himself he has talks with them
about a catwoman james gunn did it
he didn't build the universe suicide
squad and peacemaker he's just begun the
universe and they were totally you know
they worked
i think he can do it i think he can do
it he made cloverfield the biggest viral
campaign of all time like he's got that
shared universe mentality
yeah i think he's got this give me seven
shows and five movies start the apes
world a lot of people
i just love triumphant batman over here
yes
yes
[Music]
a lot of people forget that he did not
direct the first apes movie who did
let's see i don't even know james franco
director oh james franco this is the
guy's name you directed it you literally
just told me a lot you're like people
don't really think oh rupert grint
that's another guy rupert rupert the
chat right now
chat guys in the chat who who directed
who directed dot poker you directed rise
of the planet of the apes or yeah rise
yeah john know you're planning to the
age of movies i mean obviously guys
sorry
anymore
yeah okay rupert wyatt rupert
was eventually right didn't he was the
guy who got divorced when he made uh uh
snow white in the huntsman yeah we don't
talk about that sorry anyway
moving
collision
i want
what did you find it i would love
peacemaking or sequel oh no i was
waiting for someone in the chat to point
it out but i don't think they're
actually paying attention no they're not
they're still voting i think we're just
in the background it was
it was rupert wyatt this is probably the
most chaotic live we've had yet we're
only an hour and a half in never two
hours in nerd collision i want the guy
with the puppet as the next villain
and hey that would uh
build on the you know i mean even though
saw yes derived from seven it would
still build on the saw vibes for dopes
like me who were like there's a little
jigsaw in there
i'm with it sal g what did y'all think
about the narrating parts of the story i
loved it so much and hope they keep
doing it in future movies this has been
actually i'm fascinated to see so many
people debate this point in particular
on reviews i've debate
uh people don't all love
shall i engage in this level of verbal
jesting today debates you say debate
where on debate point me to the podium
show me the way
where are my note cards i will fight
them yeah
a lot of people are torn and think the
narration frivolous and funny enough
and i am not the biggest comic book
expert i am i am the least of the comic
book experts in the square bubbles but
to me that was a thing where every
batman comic i've ever read practically
i'm like that's the batman narration
that opens up so many comics is i'm
talking about what i'm doing well it's a
city it's square balls on voiceover
circle bubbles out loud it's a film noir
and it's also
in the sense and the comic sense that
but like people check that and that's
usually the excuse of like but it's in
that tradition so it's okay but i'm like
it's also in the direct tradition of the
comics it also has a movie that doesn't
have flashbacks so it lives in bruce
wayne's purview the whole time so why
not have this and the guy is [ __ ]
sleep deprived
is jotting down his notes in a
traditional sense and then they write
down the notes that he said you
literally see his voiceover in physical
yeah it's exactly this is his way of
dealing with his feelings because he
can't talk to anyone so he's just
putting it down because he's a [ __ ]
madman that's up there with his morning
page
that's he read the artist's way it's
called the gotham project yeah
it would be one thing if they did not
explain where the narration was coming
from yeah that then i would be like
what why is he talking to the audience
you know but hello
but did they explain it and it's and
it's not like in it throughout it's only
bookended by it yeah and uh it's like
who gives a [ __ ] guys we're here for
three hours you want to be three and a
half now
get some narration yeah
it works for me hashtag zero so is this
robert pattinson's best performance or
is the lighthouse still at the top
i still think it's a good time i still
think it's the rover
[Laughter]
is my favorite no but i think i think
the lighthouse i felt like was trying to
be an art house film and like it felt
it's hard to sit and get it wasn't
enough bang bang it wasn't enough bang
bang
wasn't it
yeah guys
or bang bang mermaids why'd you spill
your beans well
the lighthouse is very uh hp lovecraft
new england inspired like that is
more hp lovecraft than what a lot of
people say is hp lovecraft i want a
lovecraft batman story yeah
batman versus the cthulhu yes the elder
gods
batman
dave lopez that would be a good man bat
story i want that oh man
i want some marriages
i want man spider and man bat those are
the ones and the children and the batman
who laughs i want paul dano from riddler
to go up against willem dafoe from the
lighthouse ooh okay i want paul dano and
daniel day-lewis as harvey dent
why just spill your bees
[Music]
damn what's over we need dave lopez
dave
favorite aspect of the movie mine was
gotham
gotham's great in this movie best
co-star in the film and that's saying
something like the the second lead of
this film is gotham and it's incredible
gotham also great supporting character
that abandoned construction site that
they meet at all the time you can't say
a movie tries to be artsy like the
lighthouse and then go gotham second
best character
this succeeds
so yes i can say that i also said
eternals was an artist's film because
the amount of sunsets and holding hands
i stand by my standards i believe
[Laughter]
uh yes i loved the gotham what time we
go live 11 11 30 should we cut off the
live chat thirty seven let's just turn
off the stream because what's up
guys
i'm just monitoring the time you wanna
do three hours we started about 11 40.
we started about what you wanted to do
because you said rewatch see how we feel
all right
somebody in the chat says
he drinks your milkshake
oh that's right he's in there yeah yeah
yeah
that's my joke
did you think i was just naming actors
yeah
you brought it full circle
thank you bathroom boys for bringing it
full circle favorite aspect of the movie
i just love the the the rabbit hole of
cinema traditions it's borrowing from
and so committed to and i love that it
really feels like a pulp noir novel
as much as a superhero movie
just like that poster i don't know i
drive by the billboard and you just see
him with that side eye just looking at
you and i'm like that looks like a
detective movie just with batman
yeah the movie
z larson 71. boom set your
your slow pitch
you see that news uh newscaster made a
whole video about her obsession with the
score and it's her like harassing all of
her co-anchors running around things
like doing like operatic
i'm a fan she's great let's do it i hope
the sequel takes place in the winter a
flooded gotham that is now frozen could
be great for penguin rising to power and
perhaps mr freeze that's fun i like that
be fun yeah a lot of people think
penguin needs to be in like cold water a
lot of people think that he's gonna die
if he doesn't he's cold colin farrell
needs to be in cold water
not the character and he needs to lay
and protect an egg at some point at some
point yeah yeah that's the easter egg
that is the easter egg it's full of
marvel spoilers
does he like being called the penguin
i don't i thought he hates that yeah
i yeah but i would like i mean i think i
like the mr freeze idea with the cold
though
i would love to see a batman movie in
the snow that would be cool
yeah i think the visual batman returns
kind of has that yeah i think every one
of these should deal with weather
man there's guy pierce's little kite man
love in the uh comments
shaw agency
we finally got to your super chat
thank you finally stop monologuing on
every question incredible incredibly
generous how do you squeeze out the time
here
deke would love them to cover a hush or
court of al's storyline joker saved as
the overall looming big bad who's teased
in each by the way keep killing it guys
love your content and always stoke to
see what you have in store i appreciate
that i appreciate that very generous ass
super chatbot thank you for a lot of
money i think thank you so much man
kawaii it's all yours
um i believe that with the hush tease we
got in the film which was i it was so
funny because i heard the name and my
brain immediately got so excited about
hush that i stopped thinking and then
the third time i watched it it literally
says hush and i didn't see it until the
third time because every time i was like
oh and then i'm like they literally
[ __ ] spell out
uh i do think there's a great
opportunity for falcone to have botched
the murder and maybe the guy got shot in
the face and now he's gotta you know do
his hushiness uh i think that could come
and court of owls is is i think an all
but definite between reeves talking
about it patins and talking about it
dano talking about it like i think it
talks about it like it's it's just weird
if it doesn't happen yeah
he's like have we not written that
already like it's like she knows that
that was the plan he's like tom holland
right now he's just like have you guys
not read this happens ripped with
cortisone um so i think that is coming
and i and i personally think joker
should wait a bit i think the idea of
joker and arkham is really fun i like
the sounds of the lamb's parallel i also
think barry cogan is very intense you
don't need him for a lot of time you
just have some like bursts of stuff but
i also i don't know
i don't know if there's going to be an
issue with scheduling with barry cogan
because he's everywhere and if you want
to do a full batman thing like i don't
know
uh he'll make time i mean it's batman
yes and it's
the character
i think there's so much pressure to be
the joker that's that's because you know
like when you're the joker man like even
for me i go didn't really much an
impression on me like i'm judging this
whole subconsciously i find myself
judging this whole guy's performance off
of like joker 15 seconds right you don't
even get him like wait but i don't even
have an actual i think like remind
myself of like i don't have an actual
scene with him
he's obscured you know so and that's
kind of the pressure and i'm noticing
like no one really usually you're
stinging that's what everyone talks
about like if it's a marvel movie yeah
you know but what's great is the movie
was so good we're talking about the
score we're talking about the batman
we're talking about the movie yeah i do
think you know obscured through glass
not able to really see anything it's
hard to judge i agree with you you're
judging the voice yeah laughter you're
you're trying to but i've never been
unimpressed by barry coke and
performance so i feel like he would
crush it if we got a scene like if we
actually had some stuff with him like
hopefully the deleted scene i know just
because he's irish and the penguins also
actually it's not like the old country's
taking over the batman and he worked
with colin farrell and killing of a
sacred gear true second collapse between
the irishman one thing i did like about
the joker is his hair i was like oh cool
the frizzy kind of upward
i'm about it they should do a joker
verse movie just all the jokers
that is gonna turn into a cgi deep fake
nightmare because you know they would i
know they would come together and then
they would just start killing each other
five minutes yeah yeah would they kill
each other or would they kill everybody
else they would be like let's team up
we could have this city but then they'd
slowly be trying to like
kill off each other yeah yeah they
wouldn't hand place five jokes it would
be like hate working it would be like
war of the roses but with the jokers i
think it would be actually great or the
joke is
yeah that'd be great and artist reflect
somehow winds up on top
i could say that for for what they would
do with that silliness yeah
um but the camera monohand he was
perfect five camera monohands because he
had so many jokers he played two yeah
yeah he's multiple jokers i'm into that
he was great
zach galifianakis
sarah campbell just popping in to say
hey and leave a smiley face hooray for
sarah campbell all the love thank you
for showing joining and hey hey congrats
on your move by the way i hope it's uh
you're settling in well
michael mack
uh loved the flim
how about victor zazz as a villain if
done right he can be super creepy was
well done in the arkham knight game and
hey shouts out to
i'm forgetting the actor's name but are
you yawning no
i haven't slept and watched the batman
too much i think
maybe
i'm not gonna make a joke
who played him in birds of prey was it
christmas like he was so so good and i
feel i i i don't
expect or or actually probably want this
to happen but i can see that character
working in this world all right guys
listen of his portrayal but yeah i agree
that tone does work but victor zazz is
the best he's going to be with christmas
you know no disrespect whoever plays him
next but that was incredible jesus
christ guys the gotham show
i'm gonna keep bringing this [ __ ]
show love the gospel the god
who have you guys seen the show barry
yeah
i've seen some episodes who's the who's
the guy who who hides
anthony is it oh anthony yes
bald guy
carrick bros carrick
the guy who hasn't seen much of barry
knows anthony i know anthony kerrigan is
impressive he's dennis caleb mccoy
yeah yeah that's right yeah
um that's why he was showdown champ
right here this guy internationally here
guys
aren't you lucky to have me coy all the
good i've done for your factions
doing great work this season listen guys
anthony kerrigan in in gotham was
awesome as victor's ass and he was great
you guys should watch gotham this is
just a three-hour gotham ad well
i'm not gonna lie man i think the best
alfred was in gotham better than michael
kane i'd say so wow
hot take it's not if you've seen it
that's true it's not even a take for me
because i haven't seen it better than
lego alfred that's that's the question
better than michael go buckle goes
actually pretty great i just love how
every movie i've been recording your
identity batman
upload that to instagram and that's the
teaser to get people into the live
stream weirdly talk about gotham this
will be great greg will die on the hill
of trying to get you to watch gotham i
will die on the hill of being like hey
asians if shield's actually pretty good
you guys have yeah you guys have the
side missions in this year versus
joking birds of prey and gotham he's
funny but he's also a badass
like an actual
yeah relationship between the two of
them i only saw it one time
i've seen it ten times i don't remember
not more than the batman
um
anyway let's move on guys
hey nathan winning
winning did you guys see the theory that
the green liquid shot batman takes is
actually venom
and uh he's got that adrenaline momentum
i would love to see bane in this
universe
i think bane later for me like i said
earlier um but i i personally don't
think that was venom um but it could
have been i don't know what color
adrenaline is from the hospital but you
can't deny that he had the adrenaline
momentum oh yeah and they didn't know
what hit him when they got hit with that
venom uh that i believe i believe crazy
[ __ ] in the end somehow he like planted
all those explosions at the top
that was a distinction that wouldn't
fall on the crowd of people
[Laughter]
was did batman blow up the roof that's
dangerous as hell i definitely didn't
yeah it was like we did he planned that
yeah yeah i was like i don't know the
first time i saw it was like oh i
thought that was riddler business and
then each subsequent time i'm like no i
think that's batman but also hundreds of
people
blow the whole roof up couldn't just
blow
why not rain glass too
they're not enough danger drowning and
electrocuting you gotta throw some
glasses
i believe actual
i believe actual testosterone is clear
[Music]
if you look at the batman comics like
batman it's kind of huge just to land in
that one spot it's a dome it's
gigantic i need to save these people let
me flow
from the wounds that i've given them
with all this glasses at least a third
of the space of the floor there
like you guys
movie glass is not real
no i'm not talking about like film
making glass i'm saying like the way
glass is played in movies if you jump
through a glass window
you're all right [ __ ] up movies you're
always up
dust this off i'm like that's not a
glass in real life shouts out to the
nice guys when he tries to break that
window and ends up bleeding everywhere
he goes to the hospital he's like oh oh
no
great great uh if you haven't seen it go
watch that noir next eric mcintyre what
a double feature
that would be a great and hey you'd get
your laughs in uh giancarlo esposito
should definitely be mr freeze holy [ __ ]
is that a fan casting then that that's
been going around i love that i can
already see it i can see the eyes i
can't play every villain though i like
ron sephis jones as mr freeze for me i
like nick offerman as the servers
the mustache under the dome
time to kick some ice
that's real good
that was so good
what killed the dinosaurs holy [ __ ] have
you done a [ __ ] before
wonderful
i just hear his voice echo through my
head it is a great kick offer oh yeah he
would he
would like to see that yeah yeah yeah
incredible yeah and he's got such a
loving eye but also intensity so he'd
like love on nora then like murk the
batman love this guy i want to see
benjamin as mr freeze gotham
did not have a good mr freeze yes
finally some gotham disdain oh they had
it sorry
they had a good introduction but when he
became freeze it wasn't good all right
that's fair that's honestly just like
just having to walk around and freeze
people once in a while
what about what about a giancarlo harvey
dead
i'm into that good if we can finally see
a guy a good guy at least a little bit
of a good half a good guy and then a
conflicted bad guy sort of maybe yeah
well two faces like becomes a crime lord
we he has to we have to get him there
yeah that's why i like that they didn't
kill off riddler right i'm like oh my
god finally villains
have villains to carry on like and also
welcome can become this great like
source of like
villainy i think
i think
he's building like okay i'm going to
tell you guys what my dark detective
series is going to be and i feel like
matt reeves is doing the same thing
you [ __ ]
thief you
basically
he's building up the bat burst he's
building i think he's building up the
bat family and building up this rogues
gallery and then i think it'll culminate
into an arkham asylum movie i'm dying
for that i'd love that right
i want because that flag was going to
skip right there to that i think it'd be
way more deserved if we've met all these
villains yeah let's just get right to it
we should make a justice league the
second movie movie that's what they told
jesus to do batman v superman just go
right
to it
i don't want to call them they're like
baba dukes snyder fans they'll appear i
don't hey man snyder fans are great
i like no i'm a snyder
oh i we are not mocking zack snyder for
those who get hypersensitive uh
just loving paul dana that's all we're
doing the [ __ ] i you guys know how
big of a fan i have in those movies i
still think they can [ __ ] do it guys
i think justin's number
we have a batman we got a joker
everything but dc has established a
multiverse thoroughly and their nest
point is going to serve
discovery wants to do it [ __ ] okay
well and i'm sure that somebody with
money other than wb would join up and be
like yeah we'll finance some of this you
guys don't have to take the risk all of
my billions i'm gonna get a house and
put up my mortgage to finance sliders
just like this is how it's done robo eye
and zearing do you think a r rating
would benefit this movie i thought when
batman unmasked the riddler uh thug
after going off on him he wasn't bloody
enough i was actually surprised by how
violent it was to when it happened well
and the [ __ ] the the f word at the
beginning of the movie flew right past
me partly because i assumed there were
way more of them because i forgot about
the rating completely so the pg-13 works
for me because i'd rather have five of
these movies than two and i think the
budget allows for them like you can make
a lot more of their pg-13 like it's just
it's a more profitable uh and if it
doesn't feel like it hinders the film i
didn't mind it there were a couple times
that i was aware of it being like
oh that blood is the exact amount they
can do but it didn't bother me well i
think uh the way it riffs because david
it riffs so much on fincher films
which are bloody adventure films are
[ __ ] violent yeah like it really when
i espec
weirdly the scene it stood out to me as
is whenever you're at the dead bodies
like the thumb removed
you don't really get a good shot of it
yeah or the pull of blood they pull the
blood they say there's so much blood
the
when they're down
in the
i think it's the morgue when uh the rat
maze the first time he finds the rat
maze and they're they're literally
looking at a dead body of the
commissioner yeah looking at the dead
body of the commissioner and you never
see it yeah and because it's supposed to
be all mutilated from what fincher would
have done and i think adventure movies i
mean obviously they're a different genre
um but i think if they didn't if you
hadn't seen them you wouldn't notice
like if you hadn't seen finger movies i
don't think you'd notice in this movie
that's less bloody perhaps your heads i
still think it like tone and mood wise
this feels r-rated like there's a
version of this where i'm surprised matt
reeves is saying like there's never an
r-rate he said there's never been an
r-rated cut of this and it's kind of
surprises me because like really i think
he was smart to walk the line that he
did and it feels enough well and for a
year for for the past
like a three-hour r-rated movie like
this yeah
it's like it's fast that's three it's
one ask two minutes yeah exactly like
it's already only playing three times
per house in a cinema you can't also
make it rated and expect to make money
like this like logan has a faster pace
and is like hyper violent right up front
to hook your audience you know yeah so
that's why i think logan has a little
bit of ener extra entertainment quality
because
like the violence in there is so like
visceral and gory and i think that like
keeps you engaged more yeah when i feel
like filmmakers in the past decade or so
have gotten really conscientious and
i guess good at
making pg-13 movies feel like they're
rated or like portraying intensity and
certain states of either terrorism
well yeah not showing you too much but
really solidifying it in like the grit
of how they capture it and all that like
i for whatever reason the robocop remake
really struck me that way is like if you
look at those scenes like when they're
showing like terrorism overseas i'm like
this is kind of disturbing footage if
you took it out of context i also
there's this weird thing where like mega
bros mega rated bros are like it
actually wasn't that scary or intense
i'm like this movie's [ __ ] intense
like i hate when people are like it's
pg-13 therefore it's not intense because
this movie is intense and scary i mean
other people who are like
i saw this happening to comment on a
recent video of them saying the marvel
netflix shows weren't that r-rated
really and i was like they decapitate a
guy with a car door
like yeah watch any of daredevil the
punisher
jessica jones
everything jessica jones talks about
they're like you can't even get away
even the sex scenes and jessica jones
don't have nudity like but they that
still wouldn't fly in a pg-13 movie to
that level no no yeah people are and the
people are like they're gonna have to
cut them down like till what and
daredevil when that guy like literally
doesn't want to like no you can't send
me a fisk he like shoves his head into a
spike yeah i'm like that would have been
a pg-13 movie that is so violent that's
why there's a parental code coming to
disney plus not yeah it's so silly it's
uh so yeah there are those there are
those like already i've never heard that
did you make that up r-rated bro heads
i've yeah i just made that up in this
moment that's good just just now
copyrighted
trade market because that is a good way
to price
r is the only acceptable rate yeah like
if there's a poster on my wall this is
pg-13 it sucks like even if it's just
for a scene of strong language i'll take
the i want a second [ __ ] or just some
smoking or something please yeah the
cigar with penguin like then it'd be
good yeah
it sucks back then there were movies
that are like rated r for a brief strong
language yeah yeah these poor sons of
[ __ ]
i remember there were a couple movies i
did see growing up where i was like
i thought because this was rated r i was
gonna see something like kind of edgy
but this is just like a drama where they
say the f word a couple times just like
a real life
thank you for the moment of silence you
are lovely and we love you uh manuel
rodriguez
uh
how much do you feel r-rated would a
matter not i appreciate this man well um
i would say if you can rewind the video
back ten minutes
you go on a tear a really qualitative
answer
nc17 is the best appreciate the support
um dougie okay hear me out a proper bane
the adrenaline awful lot like venom guys
you feel
mr freeze mad hatter poison ivy or even
calendar man or saws
i think that one stuck in if you can
fall off
a mad hatter that's what i've been
taking man that would be
mad um instead of scarecrow
i think we don't we do there's poison
ivy just seems so
supernatural
but i would love to see if there is a
way to pull off a poison ivy i want
poison i mean in a catwoman movie
i don't want it it would be hot you know
what i mean like well because also it
gets it gives zoey kravitz the ability
to like actually show that she can
connect with someone like zoe kravitz
isn't like did she bisexual or character
yeah and like we got living with monica
dating right so but i'd love to actually
see her love someone i'd love to see
like and that would allow for the cat in
the bat when she comes back to have
impact and that would also allow for us
to feel for poison ivy so i'd introduce
poison ivy and catwoman and then i i
want mad hatter because i also think
it'd be really fun to play with alice in
wonderland imagery in this world i'd
love the idea of like instead of riddles
you've got some strange tangible
elements instead of supernatural like
alice in wonderland exists it'd be fun
to play with that stiffs all right guys
look here's my pitch for poison ivy okay
batman is uh out with the boys at the
wayne accounting firm partying it up
snorting coke you know at the strip club
and then him and the boys uh they're so
[ __ ] wasted
that they start pissing in the trees and
the park and they're ruining like just
pretty much all the grass and they they
set some bushes on fire
poison ivy's there and that's when she's
like i gotta go after this bruce wayne
billionaire punk yep and it's all
because
this is about the consequences
of bruce wayne
and now he is suffering the
repercussions and only batman could save
them okay i gotta follow a pitch we got
a movie uh it stars i don't know mark
wahlberg um maybe a uh zoe saldana uh no
no let's go let's go zoe ditching out
and then we've got uh directed by you
know like a thrill drink like m9
shyamalan and basically it's uh it's
nature uh i.e the wind oh
it's come on
like batman the happening or something
that happened like it's about john
leguizamo i think john was almost there
and mark robert plays a teacher
that's what you do yeah
get the lady in the water in the next
batman man
i think we're just having a conversation
and forgetting
riddle me this the puppet answered his
quest don't think i forgot the question
it was
i don't remember two hours ago i asked
where the tutor was behind on the street
what theater was that in this is what i
was telling you
at the very top every time like we
cannot spin forever
guys answer me this question don't worry
catwoman
did selena just abandon her cats no she
brought don't put it in the little oh
okay but just one so the rest were full
of cats okay i guarantee that was a
motorcycle full of cats they were
attached with a rope
just run behind the bike you have so
many little pockets i imagine they're
all see when batman made a right and she
made a left there were all those cats
she's following her man that's right
there's they mixed the meows very low
footsteps and meows
from the question the puppet raul ranjan
pattinson
seriously needed to work on his bruce
wayne he felt so much like batman bw is
a mask and it shouldn't be same as
batman solid detective movie he never
had to wear the mask because he was
never around people you know look we
have to factor this in we are like an
hour and a half behind on there okay
they've probably heard
extensive multiple reasonings
so uh you know i mean i'm just saying
like keep raul if you're sticking around
we acknowledge your thoughts and
emotions we probably can't change it
because whatever you've said you've
probably heard someone already
you know counter that with something
similar to what we said
so uh yeah you know just feel the way
you're gonna feel
what's the dollar symbol in front of
that i in all that is uh uh indian
rupees oh rupees that's cool i've never
seen this
i know
you and your white privilege i just
don't i don't deal in rupees often i do
that makes sense yeah we have to
calculate the exchange rate what do you
think i buy the equipment from with
rupees that's what's in the back of that
everything comes in and then we
translate for it to rupees and that's
how we do our business that explains
taxes estapon man
at the beginning
and the fear of criminals both the
shadows in that signal i was in from the
moment on to me that is batman
yes
what's wrong john i'm agreeing i said
boogie which is an affirmation in my
world possessive affirmation boogie
boogie yeah and i completely agree with
that that's my that's my favorite
opening man
that's terrific it's a plus
i'm so tired i sounded drunk you just
had a little slur action
yeah batman and i'll go on record and
say i i find a distinction between his
bruce and his bathroom i see one as well
there is one's a [ __ ] boy yeah he
likes your swings a boy feel like a boy
when he's bruised he's like not he you
see a boy like that's how he interacts
with people he's there's a bit of like
an angsty childish [ __ ] to him you know
he lighted me up
i don't want to go to bruce who don't
want to be accountable
or care about the accountants even
though that's probably how i get all my
gadgets
you think you're a wayne
alfred and then he's like walking
through the funeral like oh but then
when he's batman he's like well [ __ ] i'm
batman like it's such a yeah it's just
not bruce wayne playboy it's it's bruce
wayne recluse and batman well when he's
batman you feel the boy
doing his best to embody more of a man
that's true too you know jamie
hutchinson i think i think there's a
major distinction and everyone needs to
chill out everyone just goes they're
both brooding and that's what they boil
it down to well of course he's going to
bring some of that in
well he's got to have a motivation also
bruce and bat both broke but that's part
of the point of it is that when he puts
on the mask he is complete at that
moment yeah that's the point so of
course he's going to be partially there
when he's got the yeah it's like this is
who he really feels he is
like riddler and riddler having said
that that's why he's saying like that is
the real exactly god damn it's in the
movies
[Music]
it's been driving me crazy i've been on
the internet too much
jamie hutchinson hi all loved the batman
i would like to see the court of owls in
the sequel what do you think love these
live discussions
yes yes a thousand times yet all the
elves yeah we should end the super chat
okay because he's drunk we're pausing
i'm not
it's drunk yeah
i could probably do that from a separate
window let's see we got so if you want
to read the next one i'll just uh all
right
coy my dude what up next graphic novel
purchase dark victory or [ __ ] hush
i love long halloweening you're one i
always love watching your live streams
guys oh thank you
i just wrote down uh money slash orphan
for my next tick talk to remind me what
to film next you just wrote a rap i saw
you i'm just doing i got i just thought
of a rhyme with edward nigma
ooh
what are you rhyming there i was gonna
say shmegma but it has actually
uh
i would say
hush big pharma
it doesn't actually
um dark knight returns yes dark victory
so you would have to read dark knight
returns which i assume they hurt but
also hush is a great jumping on point
for any batman book like hush is kind of
one of those greatest hits where you get
a lot of villains you get detective work
you get gorgeous gymly art you get uh a
batman at the height of his powers like
i think batman hush is one of the
greatest
approachable bat stories so i always say
people should read hush if you haven't
dude just
watch
the hush animated movie read comics
don't watch movies
except when we're talking about the
movie adaptation people read more comics
movies are doing just fine read comics
that's fair actually the saddest thing
about going to comic-con to me it was
the the first year i worked at comic-con
i was walking around i had to do social
media posts and nothing would post and i
was walking around the floor and then
all of a sudden like 12 of them went
through immediately and i looked up and
i was like oh i'm in the part of the
hall where the comic books are you're in
the artist alley so no one's yeah that's
no not even artist alley it was where
the comic books were being sold yes it's
my area but yeah so read comics hush
let's go real rejects just the nobody's
podcast says we love your reaction
villain villain videos what batman video
oh shoot you got a thousand over a
thousand people watching yeah
there was a time when it was like we
were only two hours ago 100 viewers
was very worried and i was like
what the likes are but we're so in zoom
100 that is impressive what batman
villain do you hope to see next in live
action well we said this earlier but you
probably came in late or we just got
around to your question late i was
saying i would love to see kite man be
the main villain
or perhaps i would like to see like one
of the henchmen who happened to survive
one of the fights in the batman as the
leader as the main villain who just
hasn't has a bone in pick
you beat me and my friends up and
embarrass me on appreciation night
we totally don't get as many members
oh the henchman that could be the name
of the villain yeah yeah the batman the
henchman sort of the long halloween the
hand the entrance just the henchmen just
the hints i uh i think that the only way
to get sean connery out of retirement is
to have him play kite man so i heard to
resurrect
sir billy i thought a league league of
extraordinary journal was his last movie
i thought he retired no he did sir billy
he does the scottish animated
masterpiece
i think i'm learning sean connery died
dude
this was a couple of years ago no
embarrassing probably more than that now
i want to say i don't know anyhow
uh hey eric nieble
was the best introduction scene to
batman ever 20 20 we were all a little
busy yeah that's fair i missed it that's
fair i was watching spider-man [ __ ]
i did not have time to learn i was
trapped inside my house with nothing
much to do i did not know i couldn't
find it out
completely i was missing i was watching
i blocked all deaths from my sms
section anyway
william all right william faison i'd
love to see batman vs deathstroke live
action fight it would be so gritty
brutal well shot and matt reeves proved
he'd be up to it to [ __ ] just get ben
affleck to play deathstroke
how cool would that get ben affleck to
play all the supporting characters every
rogue ben affleck i think no one
should ever respect ben affleck wanting
to
have his own [ __ ] life take away from
this
man i feel so bad for that guy like let
him be the unbearable weight of massive
no matter no matter how
we saw how this maid he was when he was
making these he's gonna be in the
director's chair with just the slow zoom
in hello darkness my friend the entire
time poor guy
ah
a leaf you're back a leaf bear all
depends on the right support system so
maybe with the right support system you
know yeah mm-hmm a good broadcast
one of her oscar dresses was it was like
a poison ivy yeah it was like plant life
yeah dude okay ben affleck that's how we
get back that's how we get him to not do
a thing he wants to do how did she stay
so
attractive oh you do notice the
illuminati exercise i think it's just
just genetics
i think she's got a lot going for a
personal trainer
she's a good energy she's in positive
affirmations
journaling
hydrating watching increased dragged
across concrete all right uh eleph
buyer lashi have you seen ben shapiro's
review no but i'll probably watch it i'm
so excited coming up he hates the film
and say he thinks more about the more it
makes him angry the complete opposite
for me the more i think about it the
more i love it look i'm not going to lie
to you guys
i'm a hard alt-right
i love mentioning all about bastion
daily wire should have made the batman
all right uh no i i uh i i don't off 99
of the time agree with ben shapiro
however he is that rare personality that
i could watch something from him once in
a while and genuinely find it
entertaining like in a way where i'm not
like offended in the slightest like
they're like the whop the watt music
video the rap
the white ass [ __ ] music did you see
that his commentary his reaction yes oh
my god his reaction is so hilarious he
just like doesn't understand what is
going on with these women he's like what
is it
wrong yeah it is so funny it is one of
the fun it's not as a joke it does like
it doesn't play like that like a joke
because he's almost colbert-esque and
that he should be a joke like he's
almost like a parody of what he's just
such a specific personality he's also
the definition of a dry [ __ ] yeah and
that's why and i saw i can sometimes
find him like
really when he's talking i'm talking
about when he's talking about like
movies or something stuff that doesn't
actually have an impact on people but
he's talking about like political [ __ ]
that i'm like i'm not really gonna tune
into this but when he's like reviewing a
films i could just find it hilarious how
he like
uh sometimes takes something
yeah i don't delight very much in people
getting pwned via video essay but i do
enjoy it ben shapiro's hot take sucks
videos so one of him like when he's like
when when people just move out of your
houses and sell them to who aquaman is
very timely for this conversation like
here it is
yeah ben shapiro big dc fan out there
hey go on to joe rogan
[Laughter]
o'reilly
get that spotify money now now they let
me have an open house a little more
vacant
a lot more people are not going to go on
now
oh hey alif wants to know who would you
cast as harvey d in this universe
michael b jordan
[Laughter]
idris elba uh
tom hardy he's my superman to be honest
but i'd say sterling k brown would crush
sterling k brown is sorry that would be
rad because he i could see him as a d.a
i could also see him really angry i
could see him playing someone that has
like a strong moral compass that's
decided like that like i think honestly
sterling cape brown would be great and
we'd finally get that [ __ ] billy
williams nod that we should have had as
harvey done
why would we get the billy d williams
because he was supposed to be harvey
knight he was supposed to be two-faced
in the third movie that timber never got
why would sterling k brown be the he's
an african-american man we've never had
a so that would be a two-face that would
be a nod because he's black yeah
so
does zerodec harden nod to tommy lee
jones yeah because he's
white no we've never had a black
toothpaste and in the comics we have and
in the movies we were supposed to so i
think it'd be nice too all right henry
what is [ __ ] up about the timber about
what happened there that is [ __ ] up
they literally whitewashed that's like
that was the literal definition of white
watching however harvey ten who was
black and then what
ring and tom allegiance
so that's why i know you're giving me
[ __ ] but that's why i want like a black
two face because like we were supposed
to
good call and people are always going
a lot of people so complain about the
other way around people are like oh they
cast this person it's like well there
are people who think who is the guy in
uh in don't look up
steven lang
the guy in don't look up who's like the
actual government representative that
they start to work with i think he could
be a good harvey dent the government
government don't look up mark ryan like
the main black
actor in the cast i don't remember that
movie very well
it was so [ __ ] like this is a
metaphor like it was so heavy-handed i
love that movie it doesn't quite do
satire so much we got him two hours of
intelligence
alex b is back reeves is hinted thank
you that uh batman has previously
apprehended this not yet joker gcpd
series
[Music]
see like
i'm having such a hard time imagining
batman not being in this show
especially with the year one like what's
like what's the year
he just like runs like in signs like
he's always like the alien and signs
like like we just see a cake
that's like oh that's batman but if
there's one
you could see it happen because of the
fact that
robert pattinson does not need to show
his face
also he could live in the shadows
striking fear in the criminal like we
could build that up where like he's
always the element in the shadows like
jaws like he pops up in two episodes
never have a scene with gordon and him
talking well they don't meet in the
movie see i've always met by the time we
get to batman year two that's what i
mean it's like you could bring him in
later i've what i've wanted for the
longest time for a batman year one
adaptation
is to live in the dark
[Laughter]
what i've wanted for the longest time
for a batman year one adaptation i've
said this like multiple times is
that you do batman year one but you
never
like just show the audi you just keep it
in gordon's perspective like you never
show the audience that
like we know because we [ __ ] know but
you don't show that bruce wayne and
batman are one and the same yeah you
don't have to do a scene that shows any
of that you just keep it in gordon's
perspective sometimes you interact with
batman
you have to go to something where bruce
wayne is there but the movie never goes
they're the same i love that idea
especially with this batman we've built
because he's so rarely bruce yeah yeah
so i'd be right it would work for this
universe that's what i mean so you can
bring that in and like like like in
batman year one there's a shootout scene
where we're batman where batman's like
about to [ __ ] up some cops and gordon's
outside
and like and so much of what gordon
deals with is like is this batman and
what the the [ __ ] he's doing is this the
right path to go down you know he's
finding himself tempted to be a little
bit more outside of the law by doing
some vigilante [ __ ] kind of going
against the books so you can have those
same scenes from batman you're one
ripped out you just don't ever have to
cut to batman monologue or something
like that you know yeah i'd love to see
a show where you actually are like i
know something in the audience like in
cass doesn't know more like year fun
walter lopez in the chat says batman
will never stop beating the crap out of
people
but this time he'll have empathy
i appreciated that
our dosh raju jeffrey wright as gordon
your thoughts love love loved jeffrey
wright and i know uh greg and i uh
you remarked this to me and i absolutely
adore the way he always refers to him as
man the casualness i'm like come on man
we gotta go yeah man i think yeah i
don't even know
what's your thing the the flippant
nature of like i got my boys dressed
like a bat like
uh i personally think and i and i said
this after our third viewing that he
might have taken over my favorite gordon
from gary old and which is [ __ ]
insane like ariel and such a good gordon
and gary oldman reminds me of the comic
book um year one uh barbara is about to
have a kid like that whole element
gordon but this the relationship between
the two of them was so strong and it's
so batman that it might have taken over
that i prefer the dynamic between
gordon and batman in this one i
but i i still prefer gary oldman but
that but i think of gary oldman i think
a lot of like
scenes in the dark knight yeah i
have to save dent yeah but also at the
end he's like i'm sorry forever yeah
like that moment i i think gary oldman
doesn't get enough credit for his the
work he puts in yeah for the dark knight
in all three movies he's so consistent
and his arc is really subtle as it grows
and changes yeah yeah i agree he's
incredible bruce wayne
also just that
i only put a coat on one boy my whole
life
and i never got that coat back you must
be [ __ ] bruce wayne i've sent so many
letters to your house
i have dispatched countless officers
to wayne manor to get my goddamn coat
back i have been cold for 30 years
i never thought
the one coat
all right boy just the one i
gary oldman has that quality of the
authority figure who i who i
like i can imagine people in my life who
have looked at up at as authority
figures and he embodies that whereas
jeffrey wright i love that he is like on
the street level with you he feels more
like he's he's served like time on the
streets of gotham getting beaten down
yeah like i feel like he's deserved time
so true but i have a crazy idea what
let's see we're we're here now keep
running
we gotta i then i gotta dispute a
copyright claim on that computer that we
just got
on this uh no on a different oh i've
been on this
this is an e-cigarette it's only zero
milligrams in here oh that really sucks
when it's zero
i missed
the the mystery
becky all right
it's okay if you position it right away
no no we got it here we'll read the next
super chat while you figure out how to
make that one
i'm going to dispute this copyright
claim is it a copyright in this video
we're currently doing no no no a
different one oh okay but it's getting
views this one so i gotta dispute it
in real time it's happening this is what
it's like to make youtube
do you want the laptop would that be
easier uh
i think so
let's just
have my ass peeking back
yeah all right or at least in the gmail
uh hey jay's content is being flipped
something already yeah with the clip
should we watch it while we're watching
it yeah let's watch it's our worst
moment just combined and because it
takes his time you can really feel
all the influence i'm going to make a
big statement that i think people are
going to see is hyperbole i think this
is the movie as much as logan was that's
going to save the medium i don't
consider it a genre anymore that section
oh good hey thanks
pdx uh pdx nerd thank you very much for
clipping us out i'm gonna share this
heck yes
uh so jay's content says bane step bro
in sequel to continuing history
so uh what do you think bane as batman's
step brother john you're gonna have to
hold down the john c reilly is gonna
play bane
and uh robert pattinson is gonna rub his
nuts on the drum kit
of love that bring that to netflix
talking about velociraptors and [ __ ]
like running around and then you could
get richard jenkins boom commissioner
gordon right in the comments
writes itself get mary steenburger the
catwoman the batman or no get uh who's
agatha get get katherine han to be
catwoman
gordon but just because of the adam
mckay universe adam scott can be the
riddler
get rob wriggled to be the penguin
it's the entire cast of stepbrother if
someone doesn't make this fan art i have
failed the city because step bros batman
is amazing what is their thing called
what worldwide anyway uh patrick ak
oh enterprise elite worldwide i forget
uh this was the best live-action graphic
novel i've ever seen i was blown away
that there were three movies in one
pretty much
yeah yep that's a great way to put it
absolutely but not feeling like it's
oscillating between the like it feels
like it blends them and and jumps
between them quite well or they're all
you know ass aspects of the city
uh
extra for seven
or christopher 7 if you're being clever
oh that is clever that's clever
nice nice hey guys
that's not your currency but i'm just
going australian anyway uh i'd like to
know your reactions to all the comic
book inspired moments i went nuts when
the moments from long halloween year
zero year one etc uh so many amazing
comic moments what is clp
um
that's a great question it's a large
amount while you answer to your
expertise i'll find it all right clp uh
i really really want this
i'll throw one answer there i completely
forgot that the comic reveals that
catwoman is the daughter of falcone or
at least like heavily implies right
the the kid of falcone is the is the
calendar man in in long halloween but i
thought there was one that that's that
pretty much implies that catwoman is the
daughter of yeah it's not enlisted in
those but i think there was it's just
not as me i i i think i know what you're
referencing but i don't know what ark
it's from but i i did feel i remember
watching that scene in the movie going
oh [ __ ] like i did say that like oh damn
yeah i gotta tell you that was coming i
was like whoa that was that's a crazy
reveal right there i think that was the
biggest surprise the first time around
and it works watching it again going
like oh like all that connective tissue
really uh for me seeing the zero gear
stuff between the motorcycle when i was
like oh they're gonna use the tech from
zero year then they actually [ __ ] did
the flooding to that level uh i was
impressed um i really liked some of the
visuals from tim sale who who
illustrated long halloween so this felt
like a tim sale drawing come to life uh
as far as like energetically the voice
over which we've talked about quite a
bit is very much year one like i could
almost see the handwriting that he has
being the handwriting from year one as
well as like that riddler scene whereas
in the diner from year one that was
really cool um the batmobile feels
almost like the darren aronofsky uh take
on your one like where it's a guy that
works at a mechanic's place that's like
really really street level um so that
kind of reminded me of like a
combination of an adaptation we never
got and the comic book itself yeah um
you know i mean it kind of felt like hey
we were going to do this thing let's put
all that together um a lot of really
beautiful stuff from the comics uh and
yeah what's clp
it's chilean pesos oh that's cool hey
shout out to chile
and uh and alex villalobos says steve
harvey is mr freeze
bring that mustache into the dc eu you
should just get jay pharaoh to play
that'd be awesome he could do anybody
uh red eight that batmobile introduction
guys oh wow
i love how that is the first time you
see it yeah yeah and then the next time
you see it he just pulls up different
like i actually find that shotgun
[Laughter]
commissioner we've talked about that's
my spot no i don't got a little batman
sign on it like the studios
he's got his little batman parking space
signal yeah
uh dude how did you feel about very
quickly the transition to the chase
because i've heard i've had debates
about it and i've heard you know
people question you know like did it
need to become a chase because it seems
very deliberate that batman makes it a
chase i think he was instilling fear in
the penguin okay i think like the whole
thing is like he's a piece of vengeance
and he hasn't had a chase yet like he
hasn't had to
show i mean obviously he didn't want to
get his collateral damage but like i do
think there was an element of hunt that
he wanted to instill fear in the penguin
because penguin doesn't fear him john
had a good uh
rationale that he was trying to lure
them away from the like there was gordon
exposed there was a catwoman
he wanted to lure them like get him in a
chase that way they learn because
everyone's got like a machine guns yeah
well yeah he's got a new z
and i feel like i cut that i cut that
out of our new rocks
when we covered the easter egg i cut it
out just to save some time on the video
oh sure and so
yeah
well yeah because like the other
instances of machine gun use in the
movie are all close quarters and penguin
has an uzi which is like way more
portable than a rifle and like if he
gets near batman's face at all batman's
done for us so i feel like that it hit
me in the shot where he's looking
through the window as penguin is
blasting the window with the gun of like
oh okay you probably needed a tank
deal with this yeah yeah yeah that's a
really cool ins i didn't thought of that
like he needed the tool that is his car
to take out penguin yeah so i think it's
it's also what you said because that
charge is is a literal challenge and
then at the end penguin's face of like i
fear this man now yeah like when she
hadn't yet yeah
so yeah and i that chase like one of the
best all righty the raider nation 33.
reeves didn't make a comic book movie he
made a graphic novel it won't be he said
this before all of you
we're going back to the age group
novels i'm going after the audience now
yeah
yeah
weird move greg
segregated these guys just make it
awkward and attack your audience
shahzad in the chat says ben shapiro's
oracle not batwoman but oracle uh the
raider nation 33 reeves didn't make a
comic book movie made a graphic novel it
won't be as commercial as nolan's but
this is the batman i wanted it was
perfect i literally made a tick tock
today about the box office and i was
like for a low budget film it's
incredible that it's already made 128
which is the second film of the pandemic
era to clear 100 million is opening
weekend but i said low budget and people
are like it cost 200 million yeah it
cost 100 extra millions they were
inventing covet protocols this was
originally 100 million budget so even
200 million dollars is less than the
average superhero film which is 250 275
thereabouts 100 million budget this
movie's insane i think it's really smart
for matt reeves to keep making things in
this one to 150 range so that way it can
stay as authentic and doesn't need to be
as broad strokes to the audience as
nolan um
but that's just me i'd love to have more
indies like logan and this
i concur with these statements
heavily
i forgot what i'm dispute i forgot what
i did to dispute that claim um
there was a point here to be made that i
can't remember
at all right now
he made a graphic novel it won't be as
commercial as nolan's because
this is the batman bro
oh
i
took my friends um tony courtney
and i thought they were going to be
bored out of their minds i really
thought they would be very bored uh just
i don't really know their taste in
movies but they don't really watch like
they're they're
you know i mean tony does but
for some reason somebody just told me
they're just like regular folks you know
they're not like reading comics or
anything like that you know they're not
like this is what batman has to they're
not they're not like those people
and then uh they watched it and they
were like that was fantastic that was
like a great detective movie it kind of
reminded me of sevens they're saying
these things and i was like okay so yeah
you don't have to they're not like film
but like they really have like a dog
walking business that's like their life
you know so that's great
there's just people right not one dog in
the movie they're they're except the
swimming regular folks
we shouldn't do that what's happening
here oh i thought
i thought we were being we were i
thought i was like oh no we got to be
considerate uh we thought we weren't no
we just love your insights i shot we
shot that dc leagues the super pets
trailer reaction and i gotta still edit
that
well the live stream is done now
that's what i thought we were going to
oh man
julian marian says robert pattinson is
batman
life of nate says pattinson's batman
voice was the best
damn
those two stacked together come on you
got some good looking audience members
man boogie that's true that's true you
guys should get together
this little tiny image of you guys from
like six feet away
like you guys are attractive human
beings
i don't actually know what you look like
but i'll just i know
i learned that today yeah
the mayor's wife and son
possibly had the worst week
first the father died then a car burst
through in his funeral and find the city
they didn't think about it they did have
the worst weed
also the idea that they just go home
each night like [ __ ] that's gotta be the
worst day of my life and then wake up
like we don't see them going home and
just being like oh [ __ ] and then like
the next day the brothers got it out for
this kid man
hood that is awful that's really good
that is [ __ ] hilarious also potato
alliance i'm going to say is because of
the vegetable and i really appreciate
that absolutely i alive myself with
potatoes as well
all right lost in universal would you
like to see a robin with this batman and
who would you cast tom holland lewis tan
of nightwing
lewis tan yeah as nightwing yeah i want
a martial art you would just skip to
nightwing uh you could have netwing and
bloodhaven be inspired by batman and
then you could allow yourself your
little kid robin that way people get
this whole bat family they want i like
batman by himself if you want a whole
bat family you gotta skip at least one
rob and have bloodhaven be nightwing
inspired by the batman bring in jason
todd crowbar that kid but a big part of
nightwing's dna is that he like kind of
[ __ ] got pissed off at batman he like
but i don't know if if pattinson's old
enough or will be old enough yet to have
like because the kid's gonna have to be
a kid
five-year-old robin
batman's like 28 in this i always
imagine nightwing as like taking over
nightwing at like 26. so i don't think
you can do an arc of nightwing unless
you do like five of these movies i think
you'd have to do a younger robin more of
a jason todd if or tim drake even but i
don't and and tim drake would actually
work for that kid in the movie better
but anyway i don't know if we could get
a dick grayson arc yeah see my guitar
detective series that i've been pitching
throughout this livestream
uh was going to take place right after
the death uh like the opening would be
the death of jason todd and then it'd be
like a cut to a few years later i could
see that and then say the robin would be
tim drake and nightwing already exists
that's what i'm kind of implying is like
have you raise one robin and another
one's already a precedent and they
mentioned bloodhaven already yeah so
maybe make it more you know inspired by
man was going to be played by seth rogen
park stackhouse just says steve buscemi
is rob
hello there fellow kids
andrew
saw you guys at amc city walk on friday
i was too chicken to say hi love you
guys andrew we would have hugged you and
breathed don't come up to us
don't you talk don't come up to us but
you go up to koi yeah he wants the
attention i can't tell this is sarcastic
or not because it rings so true
guys i work on the internet
i need to know there's a voice going
somewhere was olivia in the chat people
saying chalamet where's olivia
hey olivia may be a great robin
hey
sorry i'm ignoring you john's supposed
to be monitoring the chat
[Music]
am i though
there have been times where you're like
we gotta get back to this ignore the
chat john i've been doing my best to
acknowledge the chat over here when it's
appropriate uh i i i only see the
message of you of us ignoring you i'm so
sorry olivia let me do a word search now
no no no no okay andrew probably got to
see pattinson not us right now because i
didn't see that oh yeah dude okay look
look guys if you are ever if you ever
recognize us anywhere
first off
i want you to realize we are
so much bigger than the normal people
you see
we are like
wow it's like oh my god i watch you guys
all the time this is bizarre seeing you
and they are not normal people yeah uh
so i want you to lead with that energy
of putting us on a pedestal that we
absolutely deserve michael shannon
and then
maybe consider approaching us with money
if you want to talk to them but slowly
be prepared to purchase prepare to
purchase the handshake yeah that's how
we did it photo 25 here's to interactive
if you're speaking with us the meter is
running it's like an old school cab
exactly
we are the taxi cab of fun encounters in
real life
if we click yes
yeah let's let me start the time right
here it's actually as you approach
because you've gotten to see me
so frankly i've already started the
clock it's based on icons yeah as soon
as we register one another charging yeah
sorry you'll be built yeah in real life
uh we are uh
we're really nice said you just come up
to us
we want to talk we we want to be
approached i also love talking about
comics with people like it's the coolest
thing to be like oh this thing that i
thought no one else enjoyed is now a
market so yeah come come say hi i've
seen i've had people as it happens more
often than movie if honestly if i'm at a
theater
my favorite place if someone does
approach us is at a movie theater that
that's actually my favorite place to if
if someone does come up dinner's a
little weird i've had some weird like
i'm eating and my mouth is full and i
don't know how long you're gonna what do
i do but otherwise yeah i've had it
because there's just like a weird like
do i stop do you wanna keep eating
sometimes you can tell there's someone
staring at you and i'm just like and if
you're gonna play the staring game this
doesn't happen it doesn't happen a lot
honestly but if you're gonna play the
staring game i just prefer you come say
hi because i'm we're not like
gonna be like get the [ __ ] away from you
someone had me sign a comic the other
day that made me so proud
[Music]
is you don't have to write one in
particular you could sign any kind
because i do that you're the comic guy
yeah
we gotta we gotta get some merch man
yeah that's right merch [ __ ]
there's three of us talking about
michael shannon
just a big big position guys we gotta
move on i heard a little danny elfman
btas soundtrack when the bombs go off
and batman looks out the window and sees
the water flooding the score in this
film is the best also zoe kravitz as
catwoman someone pointed this out in the
comments in our um new rockstars vid was
that
that bombs go off on the 5th of november
remember remember oh that's clever as
[ __ ]
election day but also you know v for
vendetta that's awesome i love that
great call great call someone also zoe
kravitz oof indeed
craig stratton zoeva kravitz is my
favorite catwoman now
you should have said meow
right there right now
ledrock one
shapiro hating it's cemented it is a 10
out of 10 for me
agreed i thought you were declaring
something
by your sink
ledrock won
[Laughter]
and
text fist bump to all
right
that sounds like a tasty beverage eric
atkinson thoughts on joker being the
founder of drops let's slow down coy
what's drops drops is a drug in a few
continuities and the actual drophead guy
is straight from the comic books which
was really cool to see but drock's is
like a very addictive narcotic slight
hallucinogen depending on which which
arc you're reading uh but it's very
batman-based truck
yeah they explored some of that in the
gotham show yeah
that's cool
i like the gotham show this is um
the gotham show hour he doesn't get
enough credit and it does a lot of the
things that people say that they want in
the movies a poster who has spotted make
sure all of our moon knight coverage is
about agents of shield
it will be there are lots of potential
tie-ins my friend
i will enlighten you on all of them
agent carter hey i know how
captain carter's coming to uh doctor
strange agent carter is terrific there
it is a great show too for the entire
multiverse if you at least watch asian
carter that's great but the people are
excited because she's in what if
yeah not because of your card agent
carter is so good it's good i know it's
good tv i've heard there's a second part
of this question
a poster was spotted during production
of an ace chemicals poster where the
font was dripping into drop that is
really cool i never saw that cause i
actually avoided behind the scenes of
this or like paparazzi stuff because i
wanted surprises i love this idea uh
it's fun because it ties into the whole
drug like in the michael keaton batman
89 they do a really good job making it
so the nefariousness of the joker is the
random like you don't know what you can
wield like you don't know if you can use
a hairdryer and [ __ ] like poison is
everywhere this would do that nicely but
in a more modernized noir detective way
co-signed what's a michael keaton it's
uh he's a guy he played birdman which is
uh this one shotter um this guy easily
yeah he thinks he's a good one
we got ourselves a bird man
and then he played the vulture
which is a birdman as well i'm over dar
stern he's also in johnny dangerously a
fantastic slapstick comedy no one talks
about enough guys listen to me expected
toast 59 is here he says this movie was
incredible saw it early today it was
nearly jumping out of my seat really
happened i was overwhelmed back a half
hour in i was jumping out of my seat i
need to get comfortable to leave
it's so awesome
and the riddler was so scary love the
portrayal thank you for saying the
riddle was scary because i thought he
was too but those are rated bros they
were just like not scary enough he's
kind of scary yeah he's curious yeah and
the portrayal like the the venom not
vain venom but like the vitriol that
came out of him it was an intimidating
performance well and when the others
when the others show up at the end that
genuinely made my heart drop of like oh
that's sinister like yeah yeah we talked
about even in the trailer of like
there's got to be probably more people
in his cult or whatever but i'd
forgotten all about that and that moment
really hit that and when
i i'll never forget the first time when
when the mayor steps out
and the tv flashes and finally see him
standing right there like that oh man
that's such a good moment a perfect
moment that in fact that is the perfect
moment i think for me you know what
surprised me every time i watch this
movie
the commissioner's voice
is so high yeah
oh my god and that one cops
also the one cops voice of the mustache
that like yeah yeah he's like
sticks here john we got ourselves a
situation
you really trust this guy jim
it works because the movie is so
stylized but in any other movie that i
don't know that guy's got his one
the commissioner's voice always throws
me off so mickey mouse every time i saw
you in the trailer man i did not imagine
that [ __ ] all these wheezy guys
running gotham's law before
what's he doing here hey
ron
vigilante and michael that's mitchell
all right
give him the room
she's gonna get higher and higher as
this goes
give him the room guys everybody
a moment of silence for thomas and
martha did you know ray kroc was also in
the army with walt disney i did not know
that for that ryan thank you romwe and
ryan agreed if i ever get my animations
off the ground you're selling the toys
buddy watching you guys
makes me think that how wonderful
neapolitan ice cream is
except two of the thirds of vanilla this
time
i'm out into
pure awesomeness thanks ryan leonard but
if you approach us approach us
with cash
in person if you ever recognize us i
just imagine people recognizing us but
for whatever reason it's just playing
out as the prologue through binoculars
they're just watching us walk to the box
office
eventually they'll come in the back of
the theater
i've made friends at the gym from guys
who were like dude i watched the room
and and i just that there are plenty of
times i'm talking to them and i come
home i could tell they want to now leave
the conversation
you're a fan of that how you keep people
from harassing you is you make them one
i'm like and now you're shackling like
you're in here with me
now i see you dodging me at the gym when
i'm trying to say hi to you
i hope he's watching his stream
i feel like yeah i can see especially
the gym that's fitting uh arnov's what
did you think of batman's game
not a lot but he still packed a punch i
don't know his back too much it wasn't
big enough like they were like look how
much about bats and i'm like they're
still this game boy
yeah
he works out sometimes yeah i like
robert patton's skinny boy yeah
arnov singh thank you for the momento de
silencio hunter coulter do you think it
would be a good idea to bring in the bat
family somewhere along the way or even
just a robin or how about alicia
silverstone bring her back it all
depends on tone and how you handle it i
think it rot matt robert pattinson wants
a robin real bad we present him a lot
yeah he just really he wants one in real
life i think he could do some really
interesting character work because he's
playing such a young boy that's stifled
so it'd be cool to see him as a paternal
figure exactly yeah
his whole character is traumatized from
not having his parents and they show
that really beautifully and that's what
i mean it would be such an interesting i
think it would be fascinating to do it
with a great actor
robert patson and tom hall
yes yes mr wayne
oh crap
oh crap he would be like the michael
sarah in
in lego batman what's that movie they
did together the netflix movies
[Music]
[Laughter]
holy [ __ ] no one pointed out i was
recording the whole time i forgot
jacob bible oh the author of the bible
oh dude your autobiography is amazing
actually
might be maybe just the theater i went
to but you could tell the children who
grew up on disney marvel violence were
pretty uncomfortable i mean even if you
didn't grow up on the disney marvel
violence
he's uncomfortable too it's not not
intense like it's a very there are
adults who are like that's a little
uncomfortable that's a lot
hey alan t wants to know did you like
the part where bully mcguire showed up i
i did i loved it you got some dirt in
your head i love ha ha and then batman
just looks at him and goes
[Laughter]
karen taylor hey guys matt reed super
chat oh golly thank you uh
hey guys matt reeves understood that
bruce and batman is a broken person who
watches bruce wayne and thought yeah
that guy is a vigilante vengeance
thoughts robert pattinson is phenomenal
in this movie nah he's too skinny to be
the best little [ __ ] guy
this [ __ ] guy doesn't even do his car
i'm not worried about bruises this is a
little boy get your boy to lift some
weights jim two sizes too big that
jacket is
there's no way he's the best
that actually is a good point like he
definitely his his weakness and his
innocence does definitely deter you from
thinking he's back no that's what i
think he doesn't come across he's
brooding but he doesn't come across
strong well they make him swim in that
suit too like this suit looks big for
him and they have the and when he is in
the suit they also show he's super suit
reliant to survive yeah like
he gets shot a lot
he does kind of walk into god
nobody aims at his mouth yeah
hey enough said new york the dark knight
came out 14 years ago and it stood the
test of time do you think the people
will still be talking about the batman
14 years from now yeah 13 years and then
it abruptly stops i found myself
watching scenes from the dark knight
just the other day of like heath ledger
scenes being like is this [ __ ] still as
good as i remember it is and i'm like
man this [ __ ] is still [ __ ] this
[ __ ] yeah it's still a cinnabon that
i honestly think this movie is like i
said at the top like it's gonna be the
thing that keeps this medium and genre
going because it's so different so
unique and now i can see this causing
like a ripple through the comic book
movie industry we'll see more things
taken seriously to this level so i i
think we'll look back on this like we
look at iron man 08 yeah this this movie
has an a minus cinemas
that's [ __ ] i really was
i was concerned this would be more
divisive yeah i was concerned i doubted
the people yeah i did too i doubted the
public and i was wrong i was like look i
think it's great but then again on
tick-tock i'm getting attacked left and
right because people are like [ __ ] you
this is the batman like the snyder
center center and like that's why i
think my animosity is not fair because
it's not the actual people it's the
vocal minority of people that are
attacking the movie because it's not
their batman but that's it's an
archetypal character like there's so
many takes not all snyder verse fans are
jerks i i just said us a vocal minority
i'm acknowledging that i was just lying
to not upset the sniders okay that's
fair
what they've done for charity and
everything i respect 99 yeah i feel in
many ways like a part of that
but i don't attack people about that
that's what i mean
yeah oh yeah i think people are still
going to be talking about this movie
especially because batman had like i
feel like batman is the james bond of
comic book movies and spider-man is the
doctor who where like they both where
you going
let someone know that i'm still filming
you can go you can leave no i'm not get
out of here you can go no we don't like
you
chris cox go home
thank you for the very generous sc love
you guys thank you buddy
make money over here big money
this is why i do live chats like a big
big talk to him more
you think they'll do no man's land i
feel like it'd be kind of weird to do it
right away well they also kind of did no
man's land with dark knight rises like
they they did something definitely they
did some of the story elements recently
enough do you know
what happens in the fifth season of
gotham
[Laughter]
is it no man it is a hundred percent
no man's land i think that's a fifth
movie thing like i think you can do it
after a couple robins are dead it's
supposed to be like in a puck
see i thought about that too but then
when you see
when you see the end of the uh the
batman like some of the shots especially
with like catwoman you're looking at the
streets i'm like okay they're cleaning
up a lot of this yeah it's not as like
criminals have taken over everything you
know yeah it's more like zero years yeah
which is the the and then they said
martial law was initiated and so it
sounds like people will also be coming
in to help and they can as opposed to
donating
which is like no one could come in yeah
yeah
national guard's coming it's way too
recent to have no man's land after
gotham apparently season five but also
dark knight rises like you can't do that
yet yeah you gotta build up to no man's
land but i think in like you know four
or five movies it'd be cool yeah just in
the next movie insert the wonder woman
no man's land scene boom done
dude
it's a good scene
mike k do you think robert pattinson
will be the type of bruce wayne to
create a matches malone party oh this is
a dope question mike k
yes i actually think of any
bruce wayne actor the one who will make
personas is the one that does not yet
have a persona like the the identity of
bruce wayne right now is the most
malleable so it'd be really cool to see
him develop the bruce wayne persona as a
playboy as well as a matches malone tech
detective it's kind of like he's uh to
to people that don't know match the
moment he's kind of like patched to
logan which is probably even more
obscure reference he's a very uh he's
well done now you got two to explain i
literally just explained something nerdy
with nerdier um he is a persona within
inside a persona as a way to uh
hone in on stuff and mislead others like
so logan with a patch on is this guy
that runs madrapore [ __ ] i'm just
getting deeper in the hole uh madrapore
is an area in mutandum where uh crime
and villainy
and madrapore is in uh a falcon in the
winter soldier and it's a it's a land a
mutant hive of another personality
man it's not that hard another detective
and in madrid of certain crime elements
william faison
[Laughter]
did you guys hear adam west batman theme
in the movie at certain points i swear i
heard hints of it overall
amazing with this i thought i heard more
elfman sometimes he said he used all of
the prior batman's to assemble his sound
so maybe they're going to hear that
fraud what's a remix um yeah so i i
think you might have i don't know adam
west batman at all so i can't speak to
that i want dr dre to score the next
movement yeah we forgot about him we did
nowadays everybody wants to talk about
miguel martinez
i love this movie
so
much what batman video game has the same
viber theme as the movie what game
should i play i would say uh
play la noire and then chase it with
arca i'm uh
yeah definitely the arkham games maybe
more
because there's some slight tone
variations between arkham city and
arkham knight
i would say maybe more akin to arkham
knight perhaps
but you know bruce batman eventually
talks more he has to talk more oh yeah
he can't just stay this great forever
not just not only does bruce wayne have
to adopt a personality but batman
eventually talks a lot more i mean he
talks more in this movie than any other
as far as like sheer dialogue batman
like
he [ __ ] goes him and catwoman all the
detective stuff there's a lot of talking
yeah but i'm saying uh you know like uh
i think there's a little like i think a
little bit of that kevin conrad can go
along oh i see you're saying okay yeah
like those long holds are gonna be less
and less so though yeah a little bit of
kevin costner goes a long way
i mean it is a water world setup dude
ezra west i hope the edward elliott name
drop isn't just an easter egg i want
pattinson to play both hiro and villain
in one of the sequels how confused would
people be if that would be like because
i know that we know as hush fans like
what that is but imagine someone's just
like well there's another rubber pens
was a also be a fun way to do like a
posh clay face combo i was going to say
can you explain that with a more obscure
reference how can you do clay face in
this world you can't do it oh you can't
he's just always getting plastic surgery
so that's hush so so hush
so hush is a guy that grew up with the
waynes and he is a master plastic
surgeon so he's able to change his face
and like he's he's been in the shadows
for a lot of bruce's life and he appears
as a guy in a trench coat with a very
wrapped face and he's a really cool
villain uh the hush story line involves
most of the iconic batman rogues it's a
really cool detective story because you
don't think it's going to be a guy from
your childhood that sudden change your
face uh so at one point he can look like
bruce i don't know if they'll go that
extreme because that seems very uh face
off uh for this universe but uh maybe
we get nicholas cage
elliott oh my god
i want it they should remake face off
with dwayne johnson and kevin hart i
want to make money i want twins with
kevin hart
that would be also great right
or mel gibson and danny glover
oh
robbie brown directed by milk gifts
genuine british pound hey guys love from
scotland
who do you guys think would be the worst
villain in the future buttons and films
i think a killer moth would be hilarious
and my leaves can pull anything off
condiment
i want in this scottish condiment
condiment king i want bruce wayne to
stroll up in a subway
king's just
oh my god you can also bridge the blood
gap with ketchup there it is everybody
now you can make the r-rated movie you
want to get a cat
guys we're going adam west with this
condiment king that's what people want
plus they need a new mayor maybe they
get a king instead nerd collision we got
a speed round
this movie could be oscar worthy
paul dano best supporting actor the
batman best picture for 2023 maybe rpad
for the best actor nomination
yes john
collison i agree all the oscar
nominations i would love that it won't
happen but also colin farrell should get
some love for this i think colin farrell
disappointing i think this should
definitely have makeup it'll get all
right it's better yet it'll give us
better than the nomination
uh
joaquin phoenix joker or jared leto
joker debut batman 2 movie with robert
pattinson riddler and scarecrow and
joker team up against batman
i don't want a single one of those
jokers to touch
no disrespect to moises uh but but
joaquin phoenix's joker already met
bruce wayne uh you could do some uh
timey wimey flashpoint hi jinx if you
want to make that story work and stretch
it also the idea of joaquin phoenix's uh
joker being an unreliable narrator you
could have him think of thomas wayne as
corrupt in canon of this universe
because basically you could say that
thomas wayne being corrupt by way of the
riddler is a corrupt joaquin phoenix's
take on thomas wayne's those universes
could share but i'd like them not to
goody
[Laughter]
hi how are you guys we are good the dark
knight rises bane would you guys like to
see tom hardy back as that character and
go up against robert pattinson's batman
probably not but it's a cool head cannon
i don't make many any sense any sense at
all
new batman um too much time ewy me for
what this universe is trying to do i
would uh actually get a new bane and
have him be played by dave bautista
i mean that's the that's the linear i
like that the fun of that choice all
right or anthony starr he's beating up
people in bars now oh yeah he got
arrested
he got arrested
or
homelander became him
[Music]
john as of right now the batman made
248 248 and a half million it was also
became one of the highest grossing
pandemic era film domestically in just
three dias it's also the first 100
million dollar film from warner brothers
since 2017's it they haven't made a
million opening weekend for five years
so it's a very big win for warner
brothers all around in chapter two they
were like
that equates to 744
million minutes
wow the money
that i did how would it do for 48.5
million people
they didn't spend a dollar on this oh i
was like i literally was like how do you
just account for you get a ticket
so i think you somehow new movie take an
average price divided it multiplied it
that's bad see i was thinking you were
trying to calculate how much money per
hour they made it's like that's a very
specific figure what's a dollar a movie
uh you guys see that dollar motion
picture with the batman
the nickelodeon this is five cents for
everyone shows up they see the batman
there's amc surcharge [ __ ] we always do
the money but we should we should do a
attendees that's that's the tricky thing
because especially the amc doing the
extra money for batman because they
charge more for batman a bunch of [ __ ]
suckers well you need to keep the
theaters a lot is that why that imac
[ __ ] was so much [ __ ] money they need
to get the theaters alive was it could
have switched it out for movie moviepass
i mean a-list yeah all you guys had
eight i had no actually i thought i
asked oh did you and uh because i got it
through
oh you have a third third party
that's yeah i couldn't help you okay
that's and that's an issue i see all
right
kiefer drummond why michelle enjoyed the
movie that was the most inside
of us talking about our experience yeah
i would like
kiefer grundman brady born on a daihy
the scene where he uses what i uh took
to be the adrenaline was awesome but
i've heard lots of people reaching for
that to have been vietnam thoughts if
you have been listening to the stream we
will know that we full-heartedly believe
that's exactly what it is and we have
echoed that sentiment non-stop about
this symbiotes are coming he's going to
be bane jay i showed up late to the
stream
well it's okay because we're late to
your car
actually you know what right on time we
have not talked at all about john
chatturo who's incredible but have you
talked about how great carmine falcone
was i loved the scene where bruce goes
to see him and was uh and has his
perception of his dad shattered you know
what i loved about this on rewatch is
that you with the creepy nature
of you can tell carmine's attracted to
selena i know yeah yeah it's so
uncomfortable the way he says beautiful
in a different the way he like strokes
her face
oh he like is attracted to her and he
has no idea yeah it's that old boy [ __ ]
yeah
there's some people haven't seen
spoilers for old boy
um but i i do think falcone like what an
incredible take because you have to see
him manipulate bruce in real time and
then you have to see alfred like undo
that damage
in a back-to-back scene and falcone the
whole time felt intimidating enough to
have something over penguin i believe it
was a hierarchy of power i believed him
i believe
and then then he goes to alfond and then
i was manipulated with bruce yeah which
is beautiful that was crazy
and that's why he's a leader like that's
what he's able to do for crime i think
like when we did our non-spoiler i
i think chatura was like one of the
first people i brought up because he
surprised me in terms of how much
presence he had in the movie yeah uh
yeah he's excellent 24 years ago today
big lebowski very different from tom
wilkinson
i like your daddy squeal like a pig
i love you dog
like a dog here's what he says
i i loved seeing john turturro just play
that like really relaxed menace yeah
he's like almost he's like he's so
unconcerned sunglasses at night just
[ __ ] vibing i'm a guy i'm running
this club i'm gonna be over here oh that
yeah like i just love his leg is is like
calm
tense energy uh hyman john jaymen john
abandoned terminal station was bat cave
hell yeah
i love that too i love that his entrance
was through the wayne like
infrastructure because we always have
the dwayne train but this was a way to
twist that wayne train with the bain
bean
train
pop culture oh but i did notice when he
um
goes down to the terminus he has to like
take his bike down the stairs
how does he get his car out
good suspension he's got
he's got it on like those low rider
hydraulics
it's my favorite training scene it's
really [ __ ] great
he's training before fighting superman
as if this training is gonna do oh it
helps
yeah boston you're trained to be pet
superman from boston i know i love how
you view every boston actress their
character is from boston
even in space bill burr is space boston
ben affleck no one can tell you from
boston
everyone from boston stays from boston
it's a prerogative guys that's how it
goes i don't like the rules
hey pop culture podcast what's up sir
how you doing bud i think the kid batman
safe could become robin robin
he just never gets away from trauma just
had a rough week and now a rough life
phencyclidine craig stratton hey shouts
out to you buddy i know you've been like
asking us to come back and do some stuff
one day it'll happen uh craig stratton
paul dano riddler is also one of the
best comic book movie villains close to
ledger's joker
i think he was a great comic book
villain i don't think anyone uh i think
heath's joker is like up there with
brando and and paul thomas i think uh
yeah like i'm sorry what's his name papa
timer sanderson's
the actor i mentioned earlier he's
retired now he's a cobbler uh daniel
day-lewis i think like daniel day-lewis
caliber performance from heath dia de
los you figured it out yeah i was just
like his hands on my shoulder that's
comforting
the more i've seen this movie the more i
really am enamored with the paul danos
yeah can you imagine that they got down
they lose out to play someone played
kite man
[Laughter]
mike dropped goddammit daniel davis
moose
the scene with joker is needed beyond
a studio note it gives riddler the real
win he wanted denied by batman and
delivered by joker's riddle
a friend
he had friends
they were out of seven square cars
they were gonna die for them yeah um i i
hear you that it did give riddler some
closure and that is important but i also
think that makes it even more of a
post-credit scene because the end of the
movie being batman victorious adjacent
with hope in the the town all that and
then you end it with like by the way the
arkham villains are still the winners
like that's batman to me so
yes i agree with you but i would still
restructure
joseph curtis the third act was
incredible feeling the despair in bruce
when he realizes riddler's plan and how
he influenced him amazing how did you
feel about that that was one of the
elements that unfolded the most
overviewings to me and especially the
second and the third time
really seeing the the change in that
scene where i'm like oh dang riddler
really was inspired by this guy and
thought he would be right on board with
him and and i love
i love what that says about batman i
love what that says about the riddler
all that stuff i really liked uh the
dynamic oh yeah no it's like the the
interrogation scene of like the
philosophy of what batman represents in
the dark knight is really
what's cool about the way it's played
out in the arkham scene and here with
the riddler and batman is you know it's
kind of similar in in the way of like
where they're saying who batman really
is and batman's like no you're garbage
[ __ ] you you know i don't know i don't
agree with your assessment
but then when the guy says i'm vengeance
that's him realizing the riddler was
right yeah you know it's it's powerful
that's why i don't understand the people
hating on the third actor like this
they're not [ __ ] owns well they think
the [ __ ] the bombing and all that it
comes late in the like out of nowhere
but i'm like no he's this whole time
he's been purging the city he's purging
from the corruption and started cleaning
up the streets in his own [ __ ] up
sadistic way because he thinks batman
would be on board for this
it's a great third act it's a great
conclusion that isn't just someone
punching each other
master thief what if joker is being set
up for the sequel and they could finish
off with the court of owls also i highly
recommend a righteous gemstones on hbo
has been recommended to me a lot lately
yeah i've heard that a lot let's get
walton goggins in this universe dude i
would love
i would love that for the court of alas
to be in here everyone wants the court
of owls but you know what
yeah i wanted to okay
[Music]
i think moyes's sobrano would run like a
girl from batman most people would yeah
i would i would in a second you see i'm
sprinting away i wouldn't i'd be that
dumb guy at the beginning of the movie
who are you supposed to be
then i'd be all the other idiots who
would be like all right let's fight him
that went well for our friends yeah
we are the only criminals not afraid you
might be the thing we've been hearing
about the past year
we should fight him yeah
guys we could take him uh lazzy warrior
thank you for the momento diesel
hungry the raider nation 33 robs bruce
is the real bruce damaged alone grieving
angry has trouble connecting to people
cause of fear of losing those he cares
about again you can feel the struggle
and the pain it's almost as if there's
something in the way
ah
raider nation thank you for saying that
beautifully said
yes yes big fan of the food
food fighter song dude i love dave grohl
and the way he sings that song is so
good
ryan platts the way i see it gotham is
flooded and ends in and ends on november
sequel idea is mr freeze comes in around
crimbus and freezes gotham to complete
eyes but it's not flooded anymore if
when the scenes in catwoman you see this
a lot of the streets are back to normal
at the very end yeah yeah we don't know
what time they should be maybe they're
on high ground let's pull up the
cemetery let's pull up uh a bootleg
right now let's just watch it again
yeah all right guys see you guys watch
this
an hour ago that is now being claimed
impressive youtube that you do this
would happen yummy pancakes how you
doing buddy from the patreon make your
danny pancakes maybe we can sleep i do
like the ryan ryan's idea about it being
like a use the holidays like because
that's very long halloween calendar
manish but i don't know if that can work
yet
you know in a batman movie with more
time spent
there's only one holiday between october
31st to november 6th
uh took a half day on friday to watch
the flick got out of the theater uh
during rush and i would mutter i am
finished anytime another driver angered
me
oh dude you just made that chase just
makes you want to drive through some
kind of big tube and blow it up with the
front of your barracuda hocus pocus your
nan
i can't your name's too long for me to
finish reading it and i want to because
it seems like it's a cool name but i
loved the scene when nirvana hits and he
monologues well he makes uh while i oh
golly oh no
way back what are you doing what have
you done
well he makes his way back to the bad
cave i got ryan
gosling vibes from the beginning of
drive with night call playing love the
vids i want everyone to know i was the
first he actually called me and said
that i was the first youtuber to say
that he's like ryan gosling from drive i
first want to say it on the internet
this one it's ryan gosling i don't ever
want to know this he would be badass but
every time he speaks every criminal
would be like
what what's that
i'm
huh
also the musta if they did the mo like i
keep thinking of the other guys but he's
got the videos that's actually the nice
guys the other guy stars a boston actor
mark wahlberg that takes place in boston
because mark wahlberg is in it does it
not
like uncharted they found treasure all
throughout boston yeah that's boston
harbor that's where that ship is boston
harbor
that's where america was founded
i feel like if alfred wasn't in bruce's
life he would be completely over the
edge i feel like alfred and bruce uh the
alfred bruce moment at the hospital
allowed bruce to step back into the
light and let him connect
you know on repeat viewings the alfred
relationship grew for me it was one of
my weak points in the first feeling but
it's subtle uh and i do think that
alfred even with his limited screen time
is a good anchor for bruce that i think
will develop in the coming films but i i
agree with you not enough dory though
frankly yeah who was she
she forgot she's she's she's a creation
for the phlegm unless there's no do you
know dory is i was making a finding nemo
reference but do you know who dory is no
the old lady who lives at wayne manor oh
yeah no i forgot like nemo the one who
takes her to answer the phones yeah
what's she doing she's just been letting
the phone ring for an hour
hello she actually got that phone call
before the bomb went off and i was just
trying to get there bro be like why'd
you hire this old lady it's story well
and i was sitting there during the movie
thinking to myself is this them doing
that preemptive sound mix or is alfred
just ignoring the phone
yeah or i i thought no it was after did
you he called after yeah it was already
an hour ago but yeah but the way they
mix that scene yeah it's like there's
there's
the phone rings constantly
through the entire moment of alfred
looking through the mail i thought it
was him ignoring phone calls because he
ignored the accountants and stuff
because they set up earlier that he's
been like fielding phone calls so i was
like oh i'll buy this somebody's
overthought this i think he was just
focused on the mail well and and now i'm
thinking that the phone's not even
ringing in that scene it's ringing from
it's just what a super preemptive time
uh
sound overlapping something in the way
you're throwing it because you're
capturing from batman's perspective
right he thinks he's calling him before
this bomb happens and then so he's
imagining he's picturing it he's
picturing alfred's slowly opening mail
he's slowly getting it out for them
away he just reads
he opens mail just doing his outfit
life of nate it's the scene where batman
injects himself to save selena for me
where he goes ham on that guy the whole
theater was rumbling in silence after
that scene uh and the whole theater was
rumbling and the silence of the scene
also when batman walked the people out
of the flood was poetic yeah it was
stunning gorgeous full-heartedly agree
with everything you said there you know
what surprised me is that they show
ridler getting caught in the trail
turning pretty much allowing himself to
get kevin spacey in the trailer yeah
it worked for me because by the time it
happened i was like oh i forgot i saw
this like i didn't i definitely i did
not forget that i saw that
yeah the whole third act is the trailers
and the whole time i was like i forgot
all of this oh lucky
well i don't i stopped watching trailers
at the after the one we did
see that's probably why i've watched
that trailer so many times
gl jr
justice league batman is the world's
greatest detective yet he never figures
out the clues on time even the riddler
thought he was a disappointing year too
i mean there's a lot of uh a lot of
shit's kind of given to him he's yeah
he's better than the cops at least
gordon
yeah he's better than the cops he's he's
yeah
gotham's greatest detective currently
and he will evolve and he will be the
world's soon enough even though he never
leaves gotham doesn't even mean much
that's true he's working on it guys he's
worried ernie bird the stoner
really disappointed with the joker barry
would have been a great mad hatter in my
opinion i'd rather have matt reeves
punisher movie than another batman
[Laughter]
lost me at the end there i was with you
yeah i would uh i i think that was a
rumor mill for a while was that oh my
god is he going to be mad hatter or
joker a lot there a lot of person who's
mad hatter but bad joker nah all right
guys we're almost joke hat
we're almost done all right it's that
time of the stream that's why you can't
start off too strong i did i did
monologues i was like don't worry you
gotta reel them in my second win
not until we're done
matt mercer's mad hatter coy davis who's
that guy look guys i just need to grab
some cashews
do it oh i'll be right back all right
i'm gonna share with the class
i'd like some cashews
oh no but you need to hit the remote
yeah we're done
everyone's in the dark
okay i'm okay so we're caught up on the
the here we go we're back to
the
uh
we will wait for you to get back we'll
cruise them no we'll do it all right
here we go we're jumping back into
stream labs greg will return momentarily
cashews for everybody yeah william
faizon is back uh the batmobile on imax
the batmobile sequence was so orgasmic
the sound design shots practical effects
batman walking up to penguin reeves is
goat cosigned absolutely and i read i
love upside down shots especially with
elements where it's like fires burning
upside down water's dripping up like
it's it's such a slow effect shot was so
and it was just so simple and apparently
they found it in the visual effects edit
like they didn't plan all of that to
that level they were going to do awesome
so it was a cool little like it worked
beautiful beautiful all right jay on yt
carmine falcone kind of reminds me of
adam sandler and uncut gems am i crazy
or do you see it too
your mangoes let's get some sandals
let's get some ad damn sandals
until now but i hear you
dude
that don't cut gems it's a [ __ ] wild
ass movie i love that you started it at
[ __ ] midnight this is fine i'll see
it eventually i'm fine
i love gold
[Laughter]
chloe davis another koi out here if your
real name is koi i'm very excited to
meet you hi real rejects love y'all
after seeing the batman i think it would
be very interesting seeing hugo strange
killer croc black mask mainly hugo
strange to test batman with knowing his
identity also
how about that damn batmobile holy [ __ ]
i think you go straight to the fitness
world even better than nolan's because
there was a rumor about the third movie
being hugo strange i think he'd be
incredible here and i also think with
arkham as a show especially yeah i think
hugo strange is coming yeah
phil crock i don't know about that
no they'll make it realistic
they'll do it like the mortal kombat
short
baraka i mean the code name
alligator
there could be something with the fact
that
the water happened and there could be
toxins and [ __ ] and it's yeah it's a guy
with like some kind of crazy skin
disease and sharp teeth or something
yeah they'll do like the origin of like
just half in the night everything
flooded yeah that i think is going to
change gotham yeah that might be like a
like an oz court moment
yeah pretty much
abraham
this is my first batman at the theaters
oh wow congrats and oh my god was it
perfection definitely my favorite batman
movie and it just gets better every time
i think about it also
love the streams especially with
koi hey thanks
just giving a lot a big big mango fruit
slice i love any situation that brings
koi into the room always happy to be
here i'm always happy to be near you
jake horror my dude
batman too mr freeze scarecrow side
firefly
with a hint
to ivy batman three clay face and ivy
two face versus penguins side anarchy
batman four arkham asylum led by joker
batman five court of owls with hush and
azrael well because
i feel like in this situation it's
partly my job to be over here like
looking at the levels and and and like
monitoring this stuff so that you guys
can spew expertise anyway part five
court of owls with hush and asriel
calendar
calendar man tease oh [ __ ] this up john
each film i gotta catch you in my throat
jake
uh that's a lot um i don't know if we're
gonna get 15 villains
uh but uh john's dying from the volume
of of sheer villainy you've brought
forth to the batman i'm here that said
this movie did have you know a fair
amount of villains and it made them work
um
but oh my god until jon comes back i'm
trying to recover it it's not working
out i'm trying so hard i like that
you've beat out a whole franchise here
and i think that sounds great we should
give money
to uh indiegogo campaign you know we
always start off
jesus christ you have two drinks over
there
drink a little bit
that cashew is just persistent
i can't drink because i'm laughing
that's why
i'm trying to scratch my throat with
speech literally four hours in we've
evolved so quickly you can see the image
of what we look like it's just so fun
born confused hi guys amazing movie
incredible performances from all the
characters batman
and gordon duo stood up for me the
cinematography is just top notch and i
have a feeling
that the batman will be nominated for
best picture what do you think good good
guys i think this year the academy is
showing their hand and going like what
if we were the kids choice awards
[Laughter]
i am a big fan of award shows and i
think the academy is supposed to be a
certain type of award show at the end
the culmination of award shows golden
globes is where you get drunk kids
choices like they're all different the
academy needs to appeal to a younger
demographic because that is the
viewership we're trying to reach so i do
think they need to look at genre content
i think they need a stunt award i think
they need to start looking at comic book
films as as any other film and include
them in them as well but i think it's
very
uh how do you do fellow kids of them to
be like fan favorite award it feels like
they're pandering and it's a little
insulting so i think next year they're
either gonna have to double down on
being hoity-toity old white dudes or
we're gonna start seeing more films like
this get approached so it's gonna lean
one extreme of the other i think at the
at the end of the day this year cutting
for the manger awards on the ceremony
was bad move i think the fan favorite
thing is kind of in poor taste
because it makes it like those movies
aren't important unless they're the fans
we should all celebrate film so i hope
you're right we'll see
all right
i've got monologue
i'm leaning
do you guys think you can go on the
riddler's website he talks to us and
gives riddles to solve pretty sure ones
um
there's sure no one solved it but you
guys should give it a try cool video
idea
i guess
boss can't do it we can't do it
truth if you solve the riddle i mean
that radalada.com they've been dropping
different ciphers i mean there are a
couple up and and eric vos has decoded
two of them so uh to your question
yeah
uh although
we have not broken any of the ciphers it
leads to like a big spoiler what if it
hacks your identity and steals your
whole life it makes you batman it makes
sense it says you are now batman it
sends a bunch of emails from your
account
you're back back my dude flev uh lol i
don't know how my message about
deathstroke led to such a conversation
about
penises but whatever the penis the
batman was a great start for this year
in
superhero films can't wait to see all
the movies yes including morbius one of
my
spidey favorite villains take care
people are strange you know i love the
flab doors except for more bees i you
know it's that one you don't hear that
too often i'm a little excited i think
it'll be fun i don't know there's
something about the way he says that
thing at the end of uh this is michael
morby is at your service for some reason
that line sold me on the whole thing i
was like that's my favorite jared leto
that's my favorite jared leto
performance right there he's done a lot
of work but him saying his name i don't
know
that's a weird chris pratt impression
nobody said to me nobody
oh
we should do a watch along when that's
available online [ __ ] yeah i'm rude of
uh gaussian gucci oh or more via
services
but how gucci seems like
we would have to do coke for it but
anyway
unchained hi greg john and coy didn't
know if anyone has brought this up but
did anybody notice the upper shot of
batman next to falcone's body with the
light flickering it's about the riddle
but i saw it as a subtle nod to crime
alley without doing the origin ah
interesting sure sure that's cool
actually that's a cool way to put it
that's a really solid notice man i like
hearing this ronin hell yeah we are a
real hangout stream today we really are
happy to be chilling
crown did you know did you guys uh
notice that the green serum batman shot
up for adrenaline and got angry uh that
must be what bane uses love you guys i'm
surprised no one's pointed out the
insane easter egg that you can see
riddler in the window have you seen that
koi that window
in the shot where catwoman walks out of
the club
earlier i'm gonna show them the part of
the new rock stars heavy spoilers did a
video on this too
i got this don't worry i don't think
i've seen what you're talking about i
texted it to a few people
i was like you gotta watch this [ __ ] in
there all right text it to olivia skip
to 11 13 is exactly where i started
all right you're gonna see my reaction
real time
watch
wait just wait for it i'm showing him
this
god damn it
get to it oh
right there right yeah i see it now
immediately before the arrow even gave
me it yep
you son of a [ __ ] that's incredible
i just needed the freeze frame i didn't
even need him to tell me i saw the
second [ __ ] thing that's what i'm
talking about
that's so early on this is about 30
minutes into the movie that's [ __ ]
incredible that yeah dude
so
beautiful
boss i haven't met him yet introduce me
to him i want to know this guy just you
you could just make it happen right you
set up a meeting with us i need to meet
this eric voss i hear in those comics
i gotta challenge this guy all right
ugly few really you guys don't know you
can see right there in the window very
early on taking photos of the iceberg
lounge
yeah people coming out we're [ __ ]
cool i don't even know all the [ __ ]
cash people coming out to all their
friends they're like ten dollars a bag
ugly
those made in california we can't waste
the drought is on all right are you sure
i'll be all right i i've choked and i
don't remember how fancy these cashews
were ugly few really thoughts
i'm just [ __ ] with you
i just got punished on camera i got
yelled at really thought i'm gonna pour
these in your mouth
you're gonna eat this that's my favorite
out of ten
juice
really thought put them in your mouth
put the nuts in your mouth really
thought the d.a was talking about
probably give you food when you're
around
you're thinking i gave you beers
that's true i'm usually in a cage while
we're filming really though the the d.a
really thought the d.a was talking about
the court of owls when he was rambling
when the bomb was about to go off going
on about uh uh going on about their
behind everything
totally an option i definitely think
you're like it was meant to be that lead
where's your messages dysfunctional
do you think that the syringe on the
livestream that the batman uses could be
the same liquid
injects into himself in later movies
i'll call you
what is the the answer we haven't given
you that
okay all right guys we've only been live
streaming for a few hours for several
days now we still got 913 people
watching what an insane group we can't
stop now going back we're gonna refresh
the supers we're gonna do one more round
people we're gonna refresh the stupid
chats we're gonna refresh the stream
labs one more time and then we're gonna
send you off to praise the lord is
literally dying
soon somebody said i'm dying oh yes i
was dying but i got better he was dead i
was like i was worried yeah it would not
leave my throat that particle yeah
i i i'm glad i didn't spray you with
starting to stream like i see other
people stream but they just seem so
casual and relaxed it's fun right yeah i
love live streaming before i've been
like
we got to be pro it's how we start off
when we start this off we gotta be pro
now
now i'm like [ __ ] it just give me a
blanket
it's christmas morning peaches sorry if
already asked uh do you all have a
favorite live-action the one from gotham
which character would you all play i
think coy could make a great two-face
yeah you deceitful [ __ ]
uh i think uh my favorite alfred is
still michael kane
um and i think that i would love to play
harvey dent and i think if you know if
you [ __ ] me up with enough caffeine i
play too faced you mean enough email
[ __ ] juice i'm ready yeah i'm in i
would love to play
alfred
but i wouldn't do the british accent no
of course i would just be me you're
authentic i would be my sincerest
i would just be like the way i sound
right do you know where my two-face is
from
[Music]
[ __ ] [ __ ] this [ __ ] joker
kid is really [ __ ] up my business
there's no difference between harvey ten
and two he's the same [ __ ] guy he's
[ __ ] but this half's [ __ ] green
because the green monster [ __ ] fenway
jones was like he's just the same guy
with a coin just flipped a lot of [ __ ]
he occasionally talks in the wii but i
flip a coin like we flip kaz after the
[ __ ] sock sweep it kid
i would uh want to play jonathan crane
that's who i would go for all right guys
green light this movie i static j hey
guys would you like mr wayne um i don't
want to
do this today
that's my office
i'm just very reluctant to help out in
all the courses mr wayne i got dishes to
bust i got it beds to turn i got mail i
got butler slowly
do you think we can see we moved to a
smaller house
we don't use any of this i dust a lot
and there's two of us who's this dory
person hey guys this old woman broke in
we just you just assumed she was on the
payroll she keeps hiding and brooms
though i didn't know we've been taking
things and no one notices because we got
too much so much stuff hey guys would
you like to see the joker be introduced
as his version of red hood first and see
him fall in the acid
this movie is going very classic comic
book so i think if there was a universe
to do the red hood storyline for batman
uh joker like that whole element where
it's an actual like cone red like
yes
because i think the acid storyline needs
to be fully shown if you're gonna make
it plausible and realistic
that being said
i don't know if people would understand
the red hood element like i don't know
if we could tell that much story but
maybe if they made the whole movie he
was the main villain but we've already
kind of met him so i don't know see like
you do the red hood in my dark detective
my the stream has been me trying to sell
everyone on gotham and pitch my
detective comic series that i've i've
thought about the whole thing
you would get red hood in like the third
movie
i'm just gonna watch greg's scripts
that's what i that's what i
static also follows up by saying i
posted my question with streamlabs and
super chat because i thought the first
didn't work
anyway love you guys love you guys all
static that's sweet thank you my heart
is static for you putting me into a
shock i want the second movie to be all
flashbacks
they tell you're one in year two it's i
want my the the facts in the way i want
the sequel to be
year negative two and it ends with him
deciding to be come back man we just see
that bruce like slacking just being like
a waste of space
yeah and then eventually it's like you
know what this city sucks i got i should
really do something i want to see the
fictional movie i kind of whether we
have jeffrey gordon your thoughts i
think we're above that one
yes you know what they're doing with
light year
how i want to see that but with the
movie that the wayne family was watching
i want to see them watch
her just play
like mystery science theater with the
wayne family oh this one killed in 2001
would that make it like antonio banderas
zoro sometimes it's a play
oh that's true
only nolan though i think i think it's
usually zoro
like every version well cause it's zoro
inspired batman chill level tv has a
question for greg
for greg who would win in a fight
between christian bale's batman ben
affleck's batman and robert pattinson's
batman why for greg because i know you
have thoughts on this
oh dude afflecks for sure athletics will
win yeah and he'll do a one workout
before the fight that's like trying to
unnecessarily exhaust his body before
fighting and then he'll show up in the
metal suit
only one of these batman's from boston
that's so funny
exactly [ __ ]
you want to come into my city
yeah no but it's clearly ben affleck
he's going to take out these british and
welsh boys i mean the order from
fighting will go baffling bats and
bale
yeah we get his [ __ ]
but he would be the scariest on set bail
with the look at his ass but yeah you
know yeah i love me and then [ __ ]
professor just like doing that [ __ ]
punch at the beginning yes a lot of
pensions jdm edits paul david there were
no like sneaking up hanging upside down
[ __ ] which i kind of wish we got one
he was lurking i wish he would sleep
upside down that one shot of him up in
the club yeah yeah before there's before
he like watched in the show yeah but i
want like i love that sean batman
mckenzie's like where
here
it's actually really soft here
you're kind of over you really didn't
yeah you did the terminator salvation
yeah i did
i did the tom the the the terminator
salvation was the one with the the sound
guy right or the the dp that kept
getting in his life yeah that's the only
terminator with christian bailey there's
a reason for that because that's it
i love you well we used to listen to the
remix all the time man that was so early
internet what don't you [ __ ]
understand dude
anyway actually i listened to the
original you died
you hipster
the original i've probably lost count of
the and it hasn't happened recently but
i've lost count on the amount of times
i've come in and and caught greg
listening to either the christian bale
rant or one of the many mel gibson's
leaked voicemails just love rage
embarrassing rage moments what's funny
is the dude that he's talking to that
the mic is a buddy of mine tom like the
actual guy he's referring to as tom is
like someone i know oh so like i know
that dude that likes when i hear that
now i'm like wait a second that's
someone i know being assaulted verbally
by christian bale oh we gotta unpack we
should have that guy [ __ ] ass he will
watch it with tom
let's do a reaction to the rant
what is it like to relive this traumatic
experience from set said he's the nicest
guy in the world it's just like when you
hear that bail around he's just so
he's so enraged he's
without knowing any of the context
leading in you're just like this is
ridiculous
but with context it makes sense like
he's done like 20 takes the dp's one
main job is to know a shot so he's the
one [ __ ] up getting in the shot
and the fact that like it's an emotional
scene i'm i'm team bale on that ramp
he's sorry he's so mad
sometimes you get angry there's no
reason to get that mad
yeah
it's the kind of mad where if you're
there on set you would have to like
really try hard not to kind of giggle
because it is the stage over there even
mcgee was like
[Laughter]
i'm team bale on the rant me too i want
another one
hey dm edits voldano's riddler was
menacing i was honestly shocked this
movie didn't get the r rating which
riddler scene had you on the edge of
your seat mine was colson's riddles at
the funeral i i love the way he really
plays that scene like some kind of
carnival barker judge yeah and through a
phone no less like he's not physically
there like it ties into the later when
he's like i'm all up here i'm not
physical and he's physically never there
yeah and and just the way that he talks
to him like this look like condescension
just like you know you were supposed to
be an armed justice in the city were you
not mr coulson like it sounds like a
trial and uh yeah it's wonderful
uh i i love so many of his scenes
well it's like he's putting the da on
trial yeah when the da's usually putting
the precise which is how two-face
happened as well a lot of courtroom
stuff ab fabs and still alive
and he's two-faced they only blew half
his face off
how did batman survive that he's got a
very strong suit it's his chin though
his chin was exposed
how did he not get any cuts or bruises
on his chin
too handsome he walked out perfectly
fine two things bounce off that's his
superpower for reals gareth hood it is
so nice to see you after so long what
the [ __ ] girl how's it going going
on buddy
and he's a car guy i think he's out in
like saudi arabia yeah okay yeah hey
hope you're doing it forever man
yeah dude like i think of you from time
to week we got your card the big card
how's your kid man
yeah he must be an adult
hey hope you're doing well i hope you're
all doing well thoughts on the batmobile
i loved the entrance in this movie the
floor in the cinema was shaken oh dude
yes absolutely i mean so badass and i
love i don't know i love the choice of
the the make and model to go with that
like barracuda and to like make it look
all roided out
i like how the car feels like a
character yeah absolutely it feels like
his horse i didn't think i'd ever have a
new favorite batmobile and i do now like
i thought the one element of the burton
that stuck with me was always a batman
build now this is taking over
that's pretty badass yeah it's really
impressive it's pretty ba it's about
it's more efficient than that [ __ ]
one in the dark nitrogen yeah the
tumbler didn't ever work for me
somewhere seems like it's just out to
destroy the city
i will save the city by [ __ ] up its
infrastructure this vehicle is designed
for you to worry as little as possible
about all the collateral damage you are
about
on your city point of this car is you
can drive it over or through anything
jumping over rooftops
driving over cars you were costing us so
much money
millions batman you just ran over that
cop car
oh i hope you get to sit in it one day i
want to see send us a picture of you and
your kiddo in the batmobile if you ever
find one you can
chris
alieres alirez uh how do you feel about
batman getting shot so much
i think it was his impulsiveness like
he's a year two he's an impulsive child
and he's uh he just like he's very
headstrong he dives in first so i think
we'll see less and less of that as he
learns how to be batman um obviously it
took its toll but it is you know a
choice to be a berserker
and i think he still has a little bit of
a death wish so i think there's a
certain part of him that's like yeah
shoot me first i think that's why he got
exploded because he didn't like he
literally saw the countdown and stayed
yeah he's like
i gotta
ring every last bit of deduction out of
you'll learn something in these screens
these split seconds
yes
jim x mafia he didn't get shot
he got a shot with machine guns pistols
shotguns in the chat shotgun to the
chest and to the back
so i'm glad in the end he had that one
moment where like actually took him out
weak because i was like this is kind of
ridiculous not even [ __ ] not one gun
could take this one concussive blast
from uh the penguin
gang took him down which i which i liked
and then that one and that literally
took him out like we had some moments
i could see i in this mango john
you wanna hit me with a man with that
man with that man
jim i'm worried this is the one that'll
kill me jim x mafia i thought the batman
turned to hulk after the serum i love
the brutality of that it's kind of like
it's kind of like um
not to this level but when jared leto
gets his face pounded in fight
i want club
destroy something beautiful yeah
but
i love how the camera worked on it had
this like slight
following with that movement the impact
of each blow and the sound design was so
good because they they had a slight like
hum while also that whistle of like ears
distortion and then the bubble bubble
yeah and then patterson turns around
goes because i'm batman
[Music]
this is sad never mind
a whole bevy of batman quotes came to
mind and they all tried to force their
way out of my head
this one batman's really tired
venom carnate
the riddler twist of being inspired by
batman makes sense and begs the long
time question of would there be his
villains without batman ever existing
i mean there would certainly be the
organized crime but that's a great
question because batman does inspire the
pageantry and the algebra
and the you know extremity that the
villains also seek to embody uh
but i'm going to leave the floor open
for coyotes
i feel so bad because he's the one who
should answer questions like this i
literally was just gonna say i love that
in one choice of dialogue they give us
like literally three nolan movies and
that's not to despair this you know
movies but it's really impressive that
instead of doing like the card with
joker and then the the league of shadows
all this stuff they're just like what if
riddler just really want to be batman
thinks they're gonna be homies like
literally it's like i think it's a
really beautiful succinct way to tell a
story that's all
all the orphan wanted was a friend
oh the single orbits there are other
ways
other ways of getting friends man that's
true you don't have to go to all this
effort to get my very long route
the okay uh
uh geraldo torres
did you guys get any arkham and telltale
vibes
yes
yes we did
yes or no question yes or no answer and
we're moving right away
all righty we moving up we moving up
when the mouse works all right
jester's insanity
small question
if you've seen it what's your opinion on
the studios denying colin farrell's
cigar because penguin is a smoker i
think it would make it
uh i think he's gonna get a cigar in the
hbo max show
are you some sort of police commissioner
that's right
i'll be putting on my gun and badge the
second we get off here
do you work for
um i think that atrial fibrillation i
work for the penguins
i moonlight for god in your [ __ ] and
your gun
you gotta listen to this vigilante
um i think the penguin is definitely
gonna smoke at html max because it's
something colin farrell fought for and i
do think that i it's hard i'm really
torn because i think smoking is very
very uh much an impressionable thing
when people see smoking if they have any
like history of smoking it makes them on
a smoke and i think that us moving as
far from smoking is very positive but at
the same time i think penguins should
smoke so i'm excited
you mean honestly big business should be
made out of sickness
got it in the cigarette holder man you
gotta have it i think i think it's
coming in the show i think it's gonna
come
to me you gotta have a smoke
[Music]
original boston
[Laughter]
uh could we finally see an actual robin
no a fake robin we will see in the
sequel we'll see an android robin sent
by uh mr freeze you can build them up
like miles morales
i think it's 80 nightwing man i think
inspired by it's gonna be cool mm-hmm
they should you should do that man oh
yeah
dude
connie t connie
genghis khan with the akg's over here
connie real friend those are lovely you
know what when we were watching all of
us are dead i'm pretty sure they have
the same mics
in the uh sound booth studio
that's right she said just got out of my
second viewing and loved it even more
first viewing was with us love
badenson's different portrayal with him
as batman v him
as bruce he's so unsure of himself as
bruce the final scene in this arena is
so emotional oh yes especially knowing
you i can imagine you just bawling your
eyeballs out you didn't what are you
what are you doing
being here this chad was being so
generous with us
ask for a refund and we'll deny it mike
sanchez
i thought the country
but thanks hey guys
is this your favorite batman movie uh
find out this coming week is it better
than joker for you yes saludo's
the first half hour of joker i'm like
this movie is
so dark
where's the this dark where is the
crystal
oh when i got it
i got it
got it i got it all right
so the first half hour of joker i'm like
man this movie is so
good and then i'm like
this movie is slowly losing me
this movie's not that good
two this last half hour is so good it
sounds like it's a real middle truck i'm
not a big fan of
um but joaquin's always great throughout
i love the weirdest i love joker a lot
the first time i saw it then that's a
rewatch i was like
i think i really only like the beginning
and end of this video
joke joke
i'm going to tell a joke uh no joke
joker for me suffers when you do the
thought experiment of removing batman
stuff from it and i feel like this movie
might suffer some if you were to remove
the batman stuff from it but i think
there's a lot more left in the batman
than there is left in the joker if you
were to excise the batman connection i
just think the writing and joker is a
little like it's so on the nose oh yeah
like nobody nobody is a good person
nobody is everyone is terrible nothing
almost trolling in its very very
linearness like to the point where it's
like if you don't like this like it's
got a weird aggression at the audience
to it it's it's yeah i mean it's like
look at me
it's hard to describe it there's
something to it whereas this movie's
like hey you want to vibe and he's like
let's do it noir time and it makes sense
to see all that through his perspective
and yet yeah it does just still feel
like very writ large and on the nose and
like i get it like as much as yeah and
then just chalking every
logical plot hold up to
but i do think i think like i am dazzled
by the cinematography and joker and the
music and the movie everything yeah yeah
like what yeah there's a lot of joke
you're still in my top five batman's
problem top six batman's probably i
don't know so it's number six number six
uh but like i i it's it's this is
superior to me yeah the superior i still
recommend joker yeah besides the fact
that i feel like there's an hour of it
that i'm so iffy on
um there's a lot i like about it i just
don't think it's actually a great movie
it's disguised as a great movie
that you can go directly very obviously
watch the the two of uh but anyway nadir
mooney hi guys do you think we will have
the court of owls at some point ending
on a strong one always
um yes
never in fact they're going to stricken
that they're going to burn all evidence
that that was ever in the comics even
and uh yeah no more chords they should
have a thing on youtube where it just
has you could read this all like just a
list of all the super chats that way
people would know if the questions are
even asked
i could sift through hundreds and
hundreds to make sure yeah i'm gonna
double check my own question yeah uh hey
spud 1210 thank you for the momentum oh
we got d we got some more
nerd me
you were like not a strong one i
believed you
are you you could have left no no no no
i just gotta pee i'm i'm riding this out
i'm with you to the end of the line you
go home
have you guys visited the rata alada
website i have i sucked
[Laughter]
i clicked the obvious thing to click and
it showed me a cipher i did not solve it
i said too much work
eric voss solved the cipher so we're
good i said months ago that wordle
should have been a long game viral
campaign and when it wasn't i was out so
i did not go at least with the matrix
they did that
some viral [ __ ] the website yeah catch a
split second of footage that looked way
better in a split second than when you
actually watched the actual we don't
talk about matrix
oh no i think that movie might have done
it for me
broken you
from matrix the first one
no this is not how it was supposed to go
all right back to the chat back to the
chat this is a way longer conversation
two-hour boy conversation no well no
i'll jump in that conversation too do
you feel the same as him
no but i uh you know i liked it the most
out of any of us who saw it on the day
and i appreciate it as an art piece but
it's a it's a it's a weird conflicting
piece okay i'm with you there okay like
i appreciate it more as a work of art
but that's not a matrix film i'll be
watching matrix film experience blah
blah i was just so looking forward to it
because the trailer is amazing still
yeah it falls in that category of like
movies and i won't even say it's a bad
movie with a great trailer but you could
put it in that category of like this
trailer still sells me on an amazing
movie that's not the one i got i totally
was like i wanted a four for so long
then i got it and i was like i don't
know oh man i thought about a four like
they're so though not like this
not like this
[Laughter]
matrix references
zachary skulls i actually didn't care
for the riddler felt it was perfect
casting but execution was meh to me i
kept thinking let's go back to penguin
colin farrell killed it my question is
if you weren't aware i was colin farrell
would you still love it i want to ask
people if they knew it was colin farrell
or not like like the average movie goer
and see what they thought of that
because part of the part of the dazzling
effect is
that's colin farrell holy [ __ ]
performance itself was pretty i mean i
thought i was able to separate it i
think it's great too but i kind of wish
i didn't know it was colin farrell i
would i want to yeah i want to be able
to definitively know how i would have
felt but it is such a fun performance to
watch that every time he leaves screen
i'm just like bring him back and that's
why you got the show i can't wait to see
that guy long for him what a specific
casting i know look at colin farango
he'd be a good penguin
yeah you had to want colin you know that
like a sexy ass irish guy i call him
veronica make him repug
uh i feel like he uh probably approached
them because like he's a big batman fan
um and it's getting his kid's a big
batman fan so i think that it was colin
farrell being like i want to be in a
batman quite a big batman fan he's a big
bad man fan he loves the [ __ ] bass he
just did hot ones and it made me want to
be his friend dude he's the [ __ ] best
i've only met him a couple times and
every time i'm like you're as cool as
you seem in movies because he's from
proto boston people that's how it's done
i gotta stumble upon his tape without
realizing he had a tape it's uh also
going to be a friend of mine
i watched it frequently it's great tape
all right classic tape years ago i was
like watching it going is that called
barrel
surprise
sometimes you see a phone booth and
you're not expecting it to belong to
somebody you know joel schumacher
bringing it around attacking him
there it is there it is hey guys all
right how would you feel if joker
entered uh john do you remember we did
that one
uh
similar question oh he said he said he
sent it to the streamlabs yes but hey
shouts out again
charge them again yes
for the penalty of having us read you
twice
miranda b 888 long time watcher but
first time catching a lie what what's up
miranda vilcomen love and appreciate all
of your opinions what would your perfect
sequel look like
wow out of all the sequel questions
we've been asked this is the first time
i'm like i've never thought what my
perfect sequel would look like really
green
um
instead of orange took me a second i
like that joke
it could be
nice
or blue if it was if it was
okay what's the next step in batman's
arc
i
think he should evolve as someone that
doesn't get shot like he doesn't charge
maybe doke is shot but like no no he
doesn't he doesn't charge head first and
then very literally he doesn't just
choose to be shot like he starts to
develop a reason to stay alive after the
conversation with alfred so he decides
like there's a reason to live beyond
himself and then he uh needs to develop
the bruce wayne persona probably because
of mr freeze in my world um because he
he wants to like help this guy fund this
this thing uh and then his his lady gets
gets you know the disease she gets and
then he's conflicted as both bruce wayne
and batman because bruce wayne knows dr
freeze batman has to know mr freeze and
then you've got the conflict between
bruce and him and then like i have an
opening villain that would be you know
solomon grundy or something to get back
to like how his fighting has evolved and
then at the end of the film catwoman
comes home
but what is his arc as a person he needs
to help gotham without being uh
sacrificial like he grows out of his
sacrificial lamb he wants to help as a
symbol he wants to be a person that
represents hope as bruce wayne by
actually contributing money he wants to
represent hope as bruce wayne by actual
i mean by as batman by being a
figurehead instead of the light being a
warning it's a beacon of hope so
throughout the sequel he's becoming more
hopeful as both ruth and bruce and
batman and being less reckless so he's
trying to inspire more people to do good
so basically like you pick up where the
third act goes and then you escalate and
he knows that
in the second act he starts to realize
that he has to develop the bruce wayne
playboy persona because people are not
as dumb like they start to see so he's
like how do i inspire people while being
this [ __ ] playblade financially
that's what i would do i love it
my sequel
would be like a combination of wall
street and a save the rec center movie
where all those accountants finally show
up and they're like you guys are broke
and we're kicking you out of wayne tower
and then bruce wayne's like [ __ ] alfred
we gotta make sure
dory's been playing the long game
dory really just did that whole nest
against dory is and then yeah dory does
the quarterback
squatters rights are crazy in gotham and
this is actually dory's we need to we
sent someone on the test to find out
who's this dory character
oh golly busan hussein hey thank you for
the stickers
big smile back what is this little guy
here thank you it's time to blow these
up even bigger is that the real
uncensored panda
is there is there a fake on sensor pad
what is that can you see what that is
that's like it's like a little fox
oh it's a fox holding a trophy it's a
it's a little trick trophy
little
head little drop head over here let's do
one more refresh but i think we are at
uh we're caught up finally oh guys we're
done ten and a half hours later yeah we
did it we're done
and uh yeah the batman it's done
we did as long as the movie maybe it's
coming from what it is in the movie the
batman we did it
but not as long as our i think we should
go a few more hours just to eclipse our
spider-man i'm going to go to bed now
guys
go to bed all right cool we are caught
up in the stream labs and we are coming
next quick speed round of these last
ones and we go away okay let's forever
how many how many viewers stuck around
oh yeah that's the question the 600 mark
if we're below 600 we have failed this
city eight eleven eight eleven seven
jake horror
all righty eric voss is mephisto we're
very behind let's let's jump to the to
the utmost
uh yes yeah yeah vin diesel is more of a
vein trained by the league of shadows
because you know family did you guys
actually listen
what
what all right guys
let's take off let's take a little photo
i could just do a screenshot actually no
john
check this out oh that's not
yeah oh john you [ __ ] it up oh sorry i
took a photo recorder on the camera oh
that's not gonna be messed up though
you're not going to see the end of the
thing
we're supposed to be looking at the last
of the questions and all we're doing is
taking photos of ourselves when we
consume ourselves
ourselves
performing turner says maybe nicholas
holt as hush i like that a lot that's
also some fun superman casting what
about mel gibson
as
ventriloquist uh
[ __ ] scarface it should be the doll
i like this ezra west says more ninja
and stealthy like batman bruce wayne
becomes a philanthropist hosting
charities and banquets instead of douche
playboy they should go oh yeah he should
be working with the new mayor dude i
like that was the thing i liked
partly the most about val kilmer's
batman was that they actually bothered
to make him like a philanthropist yeah
that was important as the cause yeah i
agree with that i like that i could get
down with some of that less of a douche
and yes we will be the court of owls
when he you know reveals everything
it'll just be this office of walk in
there
you know and you know you guys will have
like a big life meta moment vin diesel
is freeze matt smith as hu i would love
to see matt smith in this world matt
smith this hush should be great big mo
logan says john humphrey is hush i would
i would jump at the chance for sure oh
no batman broke his arms oh no
no he's just he's doing a rude run
that's how i want batman to just naruto
run and headbutt batman's just
headbutts
if not affleck josh brolin is bruce
wayne i could see that in a different
life
it's a good like future state world uh
this riddler mustafa james you're
writing this out coy i thought you could
go i'm like
yeah
riddler does look a little bill gatesy
there doesn't he uh yeah [ __ ] boston
alex guys
we got to end this right now john has to
go home he's got many women to attend to
right coy has one thumbs up making
videos to edit
does koi's chair make him look like he
has big white grogo ears oh yeah oh i
like that yes
yes
you carry coin a little egg listen
listen
i appreciate everyone for being here i
think you guys really helped make this
live stream something special always now
uh before we go i just want to say thank
you very much for being here he's a
member of the gotham attorney's office
you guys uh you guys say helped us out a
lot thank you me talking about the
batman a lot of fun and thanks to
everybody who chimed in on our various
polls the final one favorite supporting
character everyone loves paul dana guys
and the last thing i'll say is uh before
we go
thank you to koi for being here and if
you have a tick tock
please follow koi zhandro on there
follow koi tik tok talk he be posted
and i try to post like a third of my
tick tocks on youtube too so if you
don't have a tick tock check out youtube
for show
for see you guys
peace out
my drive
[Music]
not ending the livestream
[Music]
no